Bonsoir bonsoir à tous merci d'être
d'être nombreux malgré les difficultés que nous avons en ce moment merci d'être là pour pour accueillir
Gilles Boeuf pour cette nouvelle conférence des mardi de l'espace des sciences
qui se passe vous le savez qui vont se passer jusqu'à la fin du mois d'octobre ici
dans cette belle salle sans doute à partir du mois de janvier aussi on fera une petite halte
aux champs libres pendant les
mois de novembre et décembre dans une salle d'exposition qui sera installée comme une salle de
conférences voilà on est un petit peu en nomade en ce moment merci à la maison des associations de nous accueillir si chaleureusement
et merci à toute notre équipe qui à qui ça pose quelques petites difficultés de venir
comme ça s'installer dans une salle différente et
voilà je suis très heureuse d'accueillir
Gilles Boeuf vous le savez je l' ai souvent dit c'est un ami de l'espace des sciences il est venu
très souvent je le remercie d'autant plus que Gilles qui habite bordeaux
est parti a pris le train à 6h30 ce matin pour se rendre à paris à une réunion on à y revenir
et puis ensuite pour venir jusqu'à rennes qui demain matin sera de nouveau
dans un train à 7h30 et je peux vous préciser que c'est la première fois qu'il prend le train depuis
le confinement depuis le 10 mars
pour venir chez nous par amitié pour l'espace des sciences et pour vous
Alors je vais rappeler un petit peu qui est Gilles Boeuf pour ceux qui ne connaîtraient pas encore
professeur émérite à la Sorbonne université
professeur invité au collège de France il vient de quitter la présidence du conseil scientifique de l'agence française pour la biodiversité
il a laissé sa place à une bretonne ça s'appelle plus comme ça d'ailleurs si c'est là Office Français
Ancien président du muséum d'histoire naturelle pendant sept ans voilà
Alors il a quitté donc la présidence de ce que ce conseil pour prendre celle de CEEBIOS
qui est
quoi entre un centre d'études et d'expertises en biomimétisme
c'est cela au niveau européen et puis la présidence aussi d'éthique océans
qui oeuvrent pour une consommation durable des produits de la mer
bah là on retrouve l'océanographe que tu as été pendant pendant des années tu as été vingt ans à Ifremer
et là on retrouve un autre breton d'ailleurs dans cette
dans éthique océan un certain Olivier Roellinger
Voilà on travaille beaucoup avec Olivier oui effectivement
voilà et puis on rappelle que tu as des accointances bretonne
Trois sœurs à Douarnenez et un frère à Brest
ça créer des liens
oui bon alors c'est tout parce que on peut se dire ben voilà il
il élimine quelques activités pour en prendre d'autres mais enfin bon peut-être que maintenant il se préserve un peu plus
ah bah non parce qu'il est aussi prof consultant à
agroparistech
l'institut des sciences et d'industrie du vivant et de l'environnement il est en charge de cours à sciences po paris
Voilà non c'est un monsieur qui est hyperactif comme vous pouvez le voir
ou le comprendre
et puis
et puis Gilles Boeuf ce qu'on aime chez lui
l'espace des sciences où il est venu quand même très souvent c'est qu'ils parlent fort et franc
il n'a pas la langue de bois ça doit pas..
ça t'attire quelques petits ennuis de temps en temps
Ca m'est complétement égal
Alors comme ça, c'est bien !
Genre parle fort et franc genre au début de cette pandémie
tu as dit ce qui n'aurait pas dû se passer s'est passé
Et tu dis aussi qu'il y à bien longtemps qu'on s'attendait à une
un événement de ce type
et pour le prouver d'ailleurs il suffit de réécouter ton discours de
d'inauguration au collège de france qui a eu lieu en 2013
Je n'étais pas le premier à dire ça
Et tu n'étais pas le premier à le dire donc je sais pas est ce qu'on peut dire que tu es un scientifique en colère
Quelquefois oui pas tout le temps pas colérique d'une nature mais quelquefois oui je peux pousser un coup de gueule oui
Et en ce moment tu te sens comment ?
Ah bah j'en pousse en ce moment oui
Parce qu'ils disent plein de trucs et ils font rien
Vous imaginez bien qu'il y à  du boulot quand même
Le président Macron je vous rappelle, on était le 16 mars un lundi soir vous souvenez ?
2020 il dit ce soir là à la télévision
d'abord il nous apprend qu'on sera confiné le lendemain à midi le 17 mars
Tous les parisiens ont quitté paris pour s'installer sur les côtes bretonnes
et puis il dit le jour d'après ne sera en aucun cas le retour au jour d'avant j'attends toujours
Et puis alors on a décidé parce que bon programme les conférences
Pas mal de mois à l'avance vous l'imaginez bien et on a décidé de donner carte blanche à Gilles justement on se disant
ben on va voir un petit peu ce qui va se passer d'ici
cette date de ce soir et ce qu'il aura à nous dire sur cette situation
à ce moment là bon la conférence va quand même porter je pense beaucoup sur
sur la promiscuité entre
animaux sauvages animaux domestiques et l'autre animal qui est l'homme
comment a t-on fait pour ouvrir des failles aussi incroyable à ce petit virus
il a 15 gênes on en a vingt neuf mille tous ici ensemble, il en a 15 il n'a pas de tête pas de pattes
il court pas il pense pas
et il sait pas se reproduire tout seul donc on a ouvert des failles qui lui permet de se reproduire il est ravi d'ailleurs
et il n'a qu'une obsession si un virus à une obsession c'est se reproduire et ce n'est pas le faire tout seul
donc là on lui a offert des voies royales
alors même la question bon il est pas trop trop méchant celui là
on va arriver à un million de morts c'est pas mince mais quand même
la grippe espagnole il ya un siècle c'était entre 100 millions de morts 100 millions cent fois plus
mais c'est une super alerte si on ne tient pas compte
on va s'en prendre à un autre et puis peut être que le prochain il tuera les jeunes et pas les anciens
alors cette conférence est retransmise en direct sur
sur notre chaîne youtube donc il y aura quelques questions qui arriveront sur cette
tablette mais bien sûr vous êtes invités à poser des questions aussi on va
rééditer notre expérience de la semaine dernière en l'ayant un petit peu améliorée parce qu'on n'entendait pas très bien les questions
donc si vous avez des questions à poser comme on peu pas trop vous passez  des micros
vous vous levez vous parler fort vous essayez de faire une question assez
concise et puis
et puis je suis sûre qu'on va y arriver de toute façon je suis sûr qu'on va y arriver
si tu devais donner un titre parce que moi j'ai dit carte blanche à Gilles Boeuf
voilà mais si tu devais donc à d'ailleurs annoncé fois qu'il y avait une faute si tu devais donner un
titre à cette conférence tu l appellerai comment ?
Le jour d'après.
Tu parles dans le micro c'est mieux
Voilà très très bonne soirée à tous on se retrouve tout à l'heure au moment des questions merci
Bonsoir a tous moi je suis ravi de revenir effectivement à l'Espace des sciences à Rennes
Je ne sais pas combien de fois je suis venu, mais quelques fois
une dizaine peut-être
en fait quand Maëtte m'a appelé j'ai d'abord dit "écoute moi je bouge plus", c'est vrai je suis resté
moi j'ai confiné dans un lieu assez sympa acheteurs bord du lac de bordeaux
tous les jours dans l'heure légale j'allais voir mes oiseaux
comme c'était pas une grippe aviaire ils étaient ravis les oiseaux ils faisaient des bébés, ils regardaient les humains confinés c'était magique
donc j'ai vu des bébés grèbes
des bébés cormorans des bébés
canards plein de trucs dont je faisais mes photos c'était sympa en plus il a fait très beau à bordeaux au mois de mars avril
et puis j'ai fait un peu de vélo aussi et c'est là que j'ai commencé un petit peu à me rendre compte que
le système de confinement qu'on a mis en français n'était pas idéal nos collègues allemands même moment disait faites du vélo
fait du vélo vous ferez du vélo mieux ce sera
moins vous serez contaminées, moins vous contaminer les autres si vous êtes déjà contaminé et en plus
l'un des facteurs qui sort le mieux dans les cibles du covid en dehors de l'âge
mais vraiment très proche c'est le manque d'activité physique
ce virus il tue des gens qui n'ont aucune activité physique, très sédentaire
on va en reparler tout à l'heure vous allez voir comment justement c'est un merveilleux révélateur finalement de nos faiblesses
c'est ce qu'on a fait pendant cette..
cette époque et puis la question pour un scientifique comme moi c'est pourquoi des pays s'en sortent infiniment mieux que d'autres
Taiwan n'ont pas 30 morts
La Corée 300
La Corée ils sont aussi nombreux que les français
Taïwan ils sont 22 millions. Pourquoi ? Pourquoi les allemands s'en sortent beaucoup mieux, les portugais s'en sortent aussi beaucoup mieux donc c'est vrai que
alors je suis pas là pour faire une polémique sur
confinement pas confinement comme il fallait le faire par contre la voie sur laquelle je me suis vraiment élevé dès le départ c'est quand on me dit
on ne savait pas ce qu'a évoqué tout à l'heure Maëtte on l'écrit depuis 2003
cette pandémie n est pas du tout du tout unique 300 maladies nouvelles en France depuis 1940
il n'y a pas que des pandémies hein, on appelle ça des zoonoses zoo, animal, noses des maladies qui étaient chez les animaux
et qui vont passer chez l'humain, pourquoi ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on a offert au système pour que brutalement un virus ou une bactérie
les grande peste noire c'était des bactéries c'était le Yersinia pestis,
qui venait au départ d'un petit rat kangourou de désert Chinois qui est passé après au rat
un les rats qui étaient apportées à l'époque en europe et puis qu il y avait la tétralogie avait la gerbille il y avait le rat
à la puce du rat et puis les humains et ces pathologies tuaient à l'époque la moitié des humains de la planète
la grande peste de Justinien, on est là une des chute de l'empiré romain est lié à cela, après les grandes pestes durant le moyen âge
très terrible et les deux seules fois où dont l'histoire de l'humanité le nombre d'humains à régresser contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
ne sont pas des guerres encore mois du terrorisme dont on nous rabâche les oreilles aujourd'hui, ce sont des maladies infectieuses
les grandes peste noire et puis bien sûr ce qu'on a appelé la grippe espagnole, il y à juste un siècle, en 1919
qui n'avait rien d'Espagnole d'ailleurs absolument rien c'est un truc qui était né aux états unis
qui est parti ensuite un petit peu partout dans le monde et qui a tué tous les conscrits
et comme c'était très important on était en guerre, c'était 18-19 on était encore durant la première guerre mondiale
c'était un secret d'état militaire les jeunes conscrits tués par la bactérie
le seul pays qui étaient pas en guerre c'était l'Espagne et l'Espagne  a communiqué sur la grippe espagnole
et elle est restée dans l'histoire sous le nom de grippe espagnole alors ce n'était pas du tout un pays plus touchés que d'autres
d'ailleurs Edgar Morin je finirai sur lui tout à l'heure c'est un grand ami j'admire tellement intensément Edgar sa maman est morte
en 1922 de suite de grippe espagnole
on voyait qu'en fait ces pandémies on en a tout le temps eu en fait ça a
marqué l'histoire humaine depuis très très longtemps
et
il faut y revenir pourquoi celle-ci on a réagi comme ça c'est la première question qui m'a beaucoup surpris
pourquoi ce confinement le 17 mars en France, y en a eu ailleurs,
des pays qui ont confiné, d'autres qui n'ont pas confiné, qui a gagné c'est pas évident, les Suédois n'ont pas confiné du tout
ils ont quand même beaucoup plus de morts que les norvégiens qui ont confinés un petit peu
pour moi ce qui était important c'était la date du confinement 100 jours on a attendu 100 jours
pour arrêter les avions qui venait de Chine, 100 jours !
Le lendemain de démarrage de la pandémie à
Wuhan en Chine les avions se posait à Milan
Milan vous avez vu comment la lombardie a été touchée
les Taïwanais avait arrêté les avions Chinois le lendemain du démarrage de l'épidémie
donc il ya eu deux choses, ce qu'évoquait Maëtte tout à l'heure. D'un côté, on va en parler, pourquoi, comment c'est survenu
pourquoi ça s'est passé
De ce qu'on en sait ce n'est pas si ce n'est pas si simple que ça et deuxièmement pourquoi est-ce que ça
a fait le tour du monde aussi vite la question de la mondialisation
deux chiffres
avant la pandémie un peu plus de cent mille numéros de vols par jour
Aux environs du 10 mars il y avait cent mille avions par jour qui décollaient et qui atterrissaient
c'est tombé le minimum jamais vu, on est tombé à 23 milles à la fin du mois d'avril
on a vu la planète commencer à respirer on a vu les arrêts d'émission massive de co2
le dioxyde de soufre de microparticules partout partout partout puis on a vu la nature reprendre un petit peu
quelques droits bon malheureusement je ne veux pas vous rassurer mais c'est a été largement insuffisant pour que ça change l'ordre des choses
tout ce qu'on va voir là
regarde en ce moment lui des collègues de l'ined on va avoir un petit peu de
perte d'espérance de vie en France mais très minimes 1
durant l'année 2020 et quand on compare le nombre de morts ramenés
classiquement à des événements de la grippe de 2018  de 2019
un petit peu au dessus mais voudrait voir tout à l'heure ce n'est pas des chiffres gigantesques
donc c'est vrai que malheureusement ça sera largement insuffisant pour inverser les tendances
délétère dont je vous parle depuis que je  viens vous voir effectivement en matière de changement climatique
on va regarder sur des images je veux vous passer des images que je vous avait déjà passé
et ça me permet effectivement de rebondir à travers justement le prisme de la lecture de la Covid 19
bon là je vous ai mis un écosystème tout sympa c'est la forêt tropicale
humide, en France, en Guyane
peut-être 40 mille espèces au kilomètre carré c'est un camp sur CNRS qu'on a là bas est l'équivalent marin au dessus c'est
le récif corallien on reste en france nouvelle calédonie et le récif du grand sud
5 à 6000 espèces au kilomètre carré 500 espèces de poissons sur 1 km de côtes et on n'a pas ça en france
Pour montrer un petit peu la richesse de ces systèmes
particuliers le corail en train de s'effondrer vous verrez des images tout à l'heure partout il s'en va
on a perdu plus de la moitié du corail depuis une quarantaine d'années donc des écosystèmes qui sont effectivement
très riche
marins et continentaux mais qui sont très abîmées on perd aujourd'hui sur la forêt tropicale humide
on peut faire l'image complète, parce que là c'est que la partie qui est réduite, je ne sais pas si on peut agrandir l'image
Ouais parce que là ça marche pas là il faudrait revenir sur la partie entière là
c'est moi ? Ah oui d'accord c'est moi c'est très juste, je rouspétais et effectivement c'est moi qui peut
alors que je me repère sur le  clavier ici voilà
Mais voilà c'est bon voilà c'est quand même bien mieux comme ça
Voilà donc
écosystèmes coralliens en mer écosystèmes de forêts tropicales humides c'est parfait et puis voici comment l'humain aujourd'hui
fait vivre le système ici avec Shanghai une ville où vous avez la moitié des français donc vous imaginez bien
que l' influence sur les milieux est gigantesque Shanghai c'est une tour Montparnasse par jour
Shenzhen près de Hong Kong, j'y étais aller il y à plus de 40 ans, tout petit village de pêcheurs aujourd'hui
c'est incroyable ça veut dire qu'il y a un développement d'une vélocité absolument
fantastique et impressionnante qui forcément à des impacts sur l'environnement c'est absolument évident alors en fait aujourd'hui
quelques courbes nous inquiète alors que bon bien sûr nature l'espèce qui est dominante croit-on
on va voir comment ce petit virus de 15 gènes
nous rabat le caquet de façon considérable
si vous allez jusqu'au bout
pensez à ce à quoi vous avez pensé durant de confinement
interrogé sur vous même vous avez vu l'importance du milieu familial
on a fait beaucoup de misères aux femmes durant le confinement beaucoup de misères aux enfants
J'ai pleins d'amies qui me disent aujourd'hui "si je reconfine, pas avec ce mec là j'en prends un autre"
ou pas du tout ou mieux pas du tout
une amie qui est juste qui est
procureur de la république à Bordeaux elle me dit les preuves d'agression sur les femmes ont été monstrueuse et Bordeaux est pas pire qu'ailleurs donc ça
veut dire que ça a été très compliqué dans des petits appartements étriqué où chacun avait son travail à domicile c'était pas simple
donc ce n'était pas encore gagnée toujours est il que on a quand même beaucoup à être respectée sur sa vie on a beaucoup réfléchi
et on s'est demandé un petit peu ce qui allait se passer et comment on allait faire dans le futur après
ces courbes nous inquiètes ce sont les courbes du GIEC, en haut ici il y à juste un an 25 septembre 2019 juste un an
c'est la courbe donc de l'élévation de la température moyenne de la surface de l'océan
où de la température de l'air ce depuis 140 ans à peu près voyez que c'est à peu près tranquille puis c'est parti là
ce qu'on appelle
l'accélération de l'anthropocène
et l'équivalent en température c'est ça c'est la montée du niveau de la mer
depuis, alors là c'est depuis une vingtaine d'années
la mer juste deux chiffres j'aime bien les chiffres vous savez bien il y a dix-neuf mille ans ici à rennes
cette température de l'air étaient 4 degrés plus basses
et l'océan le plus proche il était à 125 mètres plus bas pas 5 cm
125 m vous imaginez que ça a changé
tellement de façon considérable bien sûr les humains de l'époque, bah écoutez, ils se baladaient, ils arrivaient au bord de la mer
que ce soit là ou ailleurs ça leur est égal, il n'y avait pas de ville
aujourd'hui quand vous regardez le système des villes de la planète cherchez moi les grandes villes qui ne sont pas au bord de l'océan
55% des humains habitent au bord de la mer
et toutes les grandes villes du monde si j'enlève effectivement Paris, Moscou
Chicago toutes ces grandes villes elles sont au bord au de la mer
Jakarta on va la déménager, on va laisser les pauvres malheureux
s'entretuer à Jakarta et on fait une capitale nouvel au Kalimantan sur Bornéo de l'autre côté
Rio toutes ces villes incroyable sont toutes.. New York si on arrête de pomper l'eau dans
le métro de New York il est sous l'eau le lendemain
Bangkok est quasi sous l'eau donc ça veut dire que on est sur des
questions très importantes
et quand je parle avec le maire de Lacanau près de chez moi, en ce moment je suis à Bordeaux
pour lui la remontée du niveau de la mer c'est pas une élucubration d'écolo farfelu c'est un réel problème comment va-t-on
retirer ce que l'humain a mis au bord de l'eau pour les mettre où
Si je prends des petites îles, l'île de Ré je connais bien l'île de Ré, vous vous rappelez Xynthia
Au moment de Xynthia l'île de Ré redevient trois iles, sur une tempête d'une nuit,
et bien les trois iles initiales bien sûr que l'homme maintenant à rapprocher
quand vous vous éloignez du trait de côte
bah vous arriver de l'autre côté de l'île et ça s'est compliqué bien sûr par rapport à un écosystème où vous êtes loin
tout ça pose des questions extrêmement importantes
donc là c'est l'inquiétude effectivement c'est l'autre
intranquillité qui est concerné par ce climat qui change, alors ça c'est sur 18 ans, sur dix huit ans
la mer remonte quatre fois plus vite en france quatre fois plus vite
c'est quatre millimètres par an alors pendant cinq milles elle était remontée de 20 mm
donc là on prévoit des choses de dizaines de centimètres pour la fin du siècle croyez moi que ça va changer considérablement la
cartographie du littoral français des terrains
incroyablement
cher aujourd'hui je prends le cap ferret par exemple à bordeaux ou bien des terrains méditerranée
qui sont très chers demain c'est même pas l'espace d'une génération
leurs enfants vont en profiter par les petits enfants ça sera sous l'eau donc c'est vrai que c'est des choses qui sont très.. la camargue
ça fait
presque mille ans que les camarguais lutte contre l' océan
on a fait une série de digues une deuxième une troisième il n'y a pas de quatrième possible
vous voyez que tout ça c'est des choses qui sont très préoccupantes, alors je suis pas là pour vous coller la trouille
c'est pas mon message du tout hein c'est pour nous dire à tous
prenons ceci en considération et concernant le monde politique quel qu'il soit
chaque fois que je leur parle de ça, ils me disent "ben oui Gilles on t'aime bien on écoute tes conférences c'est sympa mais tu comprends on n'a pas
le temps pour ça pour l'instant on verra ça après." On n'a pas le temps de mettre ça après et voilà pourquoi ce confinement devrait être l'électrochoc
collectif salutaire dont on a besoin c'est ça un peu ma démarche d'aujourd'hui et le contexte de mon exposé ce soir
donc la biodiversité, je vous ai mis  ici ma chouchoute je vous l'avais présenté l'an dernier où l'année avant
c'est la petite grenouille de Darwin, qui ne vie qu'en Patagonie puis qui s'en va parce qu'elle supporte pas les eucalyptus
on enlève ses grands arbres araucaria entre 1000 et 3000 ans de Patagonie qui sont là depuis toujours
qui font le climat de la Patagonie.
On les coupe pour mettre à la place des eucalyptus et ma grenouille elle n'aime pas les eucalyptus.
Elle s'en va ma grenouille de Darwin. On va me dire mais on s'en fou de ta grenouille on ne la connaissait pas ce matin ça fait rien
hein c'est vraiment l'image de quelque chose si vous voulez
et puis lui c'est le petit dernier de la biodiversité il est là voilà alors voilà un truc quand on me dit souvent "mais vous
savez professeurs des espèces s'en vont, oui on est embêtés c'est vrai qu'on fait des bêtises mais est ce que vous pensez pas qu'il y en a
qui apparaissent ?" Ben en voilà un qui est apparu voilà et puis il nous empoisonne l'existence
Le coronavirus nineteen le coronavirus de quelque part en 2019
il est tout neuf c'est pour ça qu'il est infectieux comme ça sinon il ne serait pas comme ça en fait
on l'a jamais, en cinquante mille ans on l'a jamais vu.
Alors ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir, ça c'est un thème qui nous intéresse beaucoup en ce moment
c'est pourquoi en Asie alors qu'il y a énormément de gens contaminés il y a beaucoup moins de mortalités ramener aux gens de contaminés
il y a un joli papier dans Nature à semaine dernière qui nous dit immunité croisés
Il est probable qu'en Asie depuis cinquante mille ans ils ont rencontré des virus pas celui-là, mais des trucs très proches
et l'immunité croisée fait qu'effectivement c'est assez proche donc on a une certaine reconnaissance
par le système immunitaire de l'individu
de ces virus qui sont pas entièrement nouveau pour eux et donc ça cogne beaucoup moins fort en mortalité que chez nous en Europe en
Amérique c'est la cata, parce qu'on l'avait jamais rencontrée en fait on voyait que
c'est intéressant donc je vous encourage à vous vacciner cette année contre la grippe fait le tout ça c'est vraiment important
toutes les classes d'âge ici sont quand même plutôt proche de la mienne
il y a quelques jeunes
mais vacciner-vous contre la grippe, parce que sa survie c'est pas contre le coronavirus us mais ça vous aidera à ne pas choper
une grippe sur des prédispositions du corona donc voilà il est apparu et puis ben il s'est mis finalement à exister.
Et pourquoi il est apparu ? Parce qu'on à ouvert ses failles. Un virus c'est quoi c'est un parasite
ces parasites étaient là au tout début de l'histoire de la vie on a trouvé donné quelques années dans l'étang de Thau un
micro-organisme un protistes donc il a un noyau celui là c'est une grosse cellule à noyaux donc une bactérie
et ben elle est déjà bourrée de virus ça veut dire qu'en fait dès le départ de l'origine de la vie
les virus sont installés en fait je répète parasites qui ne savent pas se reproduire tout seul il faut aller chercher dans une autre cellule
la machinerie moléculaire pour qu'ils puissent se duplique et puis après il a fait exploser il va utiliser son hôte pour se diviser
explosé passer comme ça
infectés celle de la côte est
et donc il faut lui offrir ces failles et là on n'arrête pas lui offrir des failles à ce coronavirus
c'est pour ça d'abord qu'il est apparu et deuxièmement c'est pour ça qu'il a réussi à se disséminer comme ça partout
vous imaginez 100000 avions par jour qui l'emmenait partout
il y a presque tous les pays du monde, je croit que ceux qui ont dit qu'ils ne l'avaient pas encore c'est parce qu'ils n'ont pas cherché ou
pas trouver un mais sur les 195 pays de l'ONU il y à eu du y avoir
155 qui ont révélé effectivement des problèmes de pathologie liés au coronavirus
et c'est sûr que ce qui avaient des liaisons par avion avec la Chine ont été touchés beaucoup plus fort que les autres
vous voyez que
commence à sentir un comportement humain un peu curieux pourquoi il est apparu
promiscuité on l'a dit entre espèces domestiques on va y revenir espèces sauvages vivantes sur le même marché
et puis ensuite bien sûr la dissémination
effarante que l'on a connues avant les pestes elles venaient par bateau elle mettait quelques mois quelques années.
Vous vous rappelez l'arrivée des bateaux à Marseille on à  des textes magnifiques
où en fait
les bateaux, là il s'embêtait pas, il sacrifiait le bateau. On brulait le bateau avec les gens dessus et puis
les bactéries de la peste, c'était tellement dangereux..
Et puis certains trichaient, ce bateau qui débarque à Marseille, illégalement, puis qui met la peste partout à Marseille
Donc c'est vrai que..
On n'en est plus à ces méthodes là on est bien d'accord assez clair mais
il faut changer à la façon dont ces êtres vivants se dissémine donc le coronavirus on va faire avec
d'ailleurs si vous m'aviez dit y a un an quand je suis venu que ma prochaine conférence je la ferais avec un masque
on n'aurait pas cru que c'était possible
je laisse là mon masque je suis assez loin de vous donc je peux parler sans mon masque c'est un peu énervant de parler dans un masque
on s'auto étouffe
Donc ça je vous en avais parlé aussi alors les questions plus est ce qu'on est mangé ou être mangé.. Lucy chaque matin à
il y à 3,2 millions d'années se posait la question est ce que je vais manger aujourd'hui est-ce que je ne vais pas être mangée aujourd'hui
la question environnementale que vous connaissez bien avant la Covid aussi a donc énergie eau biodiversité climat etc du feu à l'énergie nucléaire
et puis toute la technologie qui sont les biotech le numérique des nanotechs la robotique
Et ça il y a eu de très joli papiers durant le confinement qui nous montre justement que malgré tous ces vœux pieux
nos dominations de ce qu'on appelle IA
intelligence artificielle qui au départ était informatique augmenté pour moi un robot il sera toujours con de toute façon
il sera jamais au niveau d'un ver de terre ou d'une limace qui sera toujours un être vivant est infiniment.. Par contre il sait faire merveilleusement des choses
Aller faire une soudure à 4 km, ça mon ver de terre il sait pas et moi non plus et le robot il sait faire donc
je pense que ce sont des outils de l'humanité mais arrêtons de dire qu'un jour les robots seront plus intelligents que les humains
ça n'a pas de sens
alors après est-ce qu'ils prendront le pouvoir on revient sur la science fiction qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure en tout cas là on en est loin
parce que le coronavirus n'en a rien à faire des robots
d'ailleurs il ne les parasite pas d'ailleurs
et puis ben simplement lui il s'attaque aux humains parce que c'est une chance pour lui
d'être passé de son hôte original le rhinolophus affinis une chauve-souris chinoise
pratiquement que chinoise et d'être passé à l'humain alors qu'au départ il ne savait pas le faire
Donc le vivant sur la terre je vous le rappelle ce sont des bactéries n'oubliez jamais ça c'est ça nous sommes un monde de bactéries
tous ici dans la salle
moitié de bactéries et moitié de cellules humaines dans le corps humain
le drame c'est que aucun polytechnicien aucun énarque ne sait ça
on leur a pas dit à l'école maternelle qui était faite bactéries les trous de nez les yeux on est beau quand même il n'y à pas
de problème mais on est fait de bactérie on ne bouffe que ça il y en a partout autour de nous qui sont infiniment plus utile que délétère.
Quelques fois hein.. Un vibrio cholerae
vous fait une toxine qui va vous déshydrater
mais n'empêche que
des millions de micro organismes partout votre
lit, vos oreilles votre nez en sont pleins encore une fois on vit dedans vous ne mangez que ça
beaucoup de produits que vous mangez vous ne pourriez pas les digérer sans ces bactéries donc on est vraiment dans un monde de bactéries
il ne faut jamais l'oublié et puis ça c'est des protistes j'aime beaucoup des protistes puisque c'est les microalgues de l'océan ce sont aussi les levures
or sans levure ben y'a pas pain il n'y a pas de vins y a pas de bière
il n'y a pas de fromages dont quand même c'est utile comme pour l'homosapiens français
Parce qu'un français s'il a pas ça a bouffer il n'existe pas
Vous voyez que tiens ben oui, alors les protistes sont de grosses cellules à noyaux qui sont uniques aussi, elles ne sont pas dans un organisme,
partout celle là ce sont des dinoflagellates de l'eau de mer
qu'on met dans ce qu'on appelle globalement le phytoplancton le plancton végétal. C'est extrêmement important je vais revenir tout à l'heure à ça
Les champignons les plantes donc les lichens aussi donc ça c'est après une éruption volcanique
sur le piton de la fournaise à la réunion et puis les animaux alors j'ai mis un chouchou à tardigrade
c'est comme ma p'tite grenouille de Darwin, j'ai quelques chouchous comme ça que j'aime bien il est génial parce qu'il sait tout faire
et puis lui il sera là largement après que les humains ce soit auto détruit en fait
Quand on me dit "l'humain va tuer la vie", c'est pas vrai, ça tient pas debout par contre les éléphants les girafes les baleines
les rhinocéros, les hippopotames.. Eux ils sont bien embêtés effectivement avec l'espèce humaine alors je rebondis sur un papier d'un collègue qui s'appelle Paul Ehrlich
qui écrit, il y à quelques années
"Can the collapse of global civilisation be avoided ?" Est-ce qu'on peut interdire un effondrement de nos civilisations
voilà le débat est lancé et vous allez voir que la Covid 19
ben nous amène quelques éléments de réponse si on fait comme ça oui
nous ne pourrons pas effectivement maintenir nos civilisations
est-ce que ça va être ce que j'appelle souvent, je fais un papier qui sera semaine prochaine vous pourrez le trouver
qui s'appelle "la Covid 19 :  un électrochoc collectif salutaire"
Je souhaite de tout mon corps de chaque cellule de mon corps qu'il soit salutaire
mais vu comment ils réagissent j'en suis pas convaincu quand j'écoute les compagnies aériennes
qui n'ont qu'un mot à la bouche : "quand est ce qu'on va revenir au nombre de l'avion qu'on avait avant ?"
Mais c'est pas la question c'est pas possible de faire ça c'est pas possible
où est la mesure où est
l'harmonie entre l'humain et le non humain et voir Ryanair qui revend la cent mille billets à 5 euros c'est pas possible
5 euros je ne paye pas l'impact des avions sur l'environnement je tiens pas compte des externalités
des cancers du sein chez les jeunes femmes pareil pour les pesticides
pareil pour la surconsommation de viande donc
encore une fois c'est pas question de tout interdire c'est pas du tout mon style de vie
simplement c'est que retrouvons de la mesure
retrouvons en fait de la sobriété et arrêtons un hyper
consumérisme si on veut rééviter ça. Le seul endroit où il n'y a pas de vivants sur la terre c'est là, sur les laves de volcans
1200 degrés, il n'y a plus de vivant là-dedans
Il n'y en a jamais eu.
Alors voilà les mouvements pourquoi est on intranquille ? Regardez, effectivement ben ça c'est typique pourquoi c'est venu
c'était avant la Covid 19
donc on est en novembre 2018 ces mouvements sociaux apparaissent pourquoi
parce qu'on a décidé sans mesures sociales antérieures
d'augmenter les prix du gasoil
quelques centimes et ça va plus
Ces gens là sont poussés à bout ça part sur les réseaux sociaux "ouais c'est pas possible"
Le gasoil est passé je sais plus combien c'était à l'époque de 1 10 à 1 22 j'en sais rien, toujours est il que
c'est la goutte qui fait déborder le vase et ils vont sur les ronds-points
et on retrouve de tout dans ces gilets jaunes et c'est très difficile de dire qui est gilet jaune
en fait moi globalement je vais prendre.. Il n'y a pas d'image
Après il y a eu des mouvements extrémistes qui s'en sont mêlés
d'extrême droite extrême gauche mais au départ ce n'était pas des gens violents et puis après ça a évolué vers des mouvements
et en fait c'est la résultante d'année d'années et d'années et d'années de négligence
Edgar Morin aujourd'hui, je vais revenir à Edgar, disait en fait au président macron "vous savez monsieur le président
quand on gouverne comme ça en oubliant une partie des gens le premier gourou qui passe il gagne."
Regardez ce qu'il s'est passé aux Etats-Unis, au Brésil, en Italie des gourous même en France on a quelques gourous.
Ces gourous sont incapables de résoudre nos problèmes actuels autant sociaux d'ailleurs
qu'environnementaux mais ça veut dire aussi qu'on ne résoudra jamais nos questions environnementales sans des mesures sociales
chaque fois que le climat change, chaque fois qu'une pollution apparaît elle a des impacts
donc c'est là que
on n'a pas pris la mesure de tout ça en fait au démarrage donc il ya un énorme effort à faire de
rééquilibrage et puis aussi c'est pas de revenir à des systèmes où tout le monde exactement pareil c'est pas ça
pour moi la première le premier équilibrage c'est hommes et femmes
si les femmes étaient non pas remise mais mise depuis le départ dans la position qu'elle devrait avoir dans la société
vous êtes mesdames un peu plus nombreuses que les garçons
en bébé il y a un peu plus de garçons que de filles à 20 ans y a plus de filles
ça veut dire que ben le monde serait très différent très très différents
les prisons en france
92 % de garçons
Ce serait 50 52 48, 92.. Alors j'ai une amie qui me dit "je paye plus les impôts, j'en ai marre de payer de impôts
pour payer des mecs ont violé des filles qui sont en prison" bon d'accord
mais tout est à l'avenant qu'est ce qui s'est passé pendant ces mouvements
qui a fait le travail fantastique en France sur le terrain ce qu'on a oublié c'est que 50% des français travaillaient pendant le confinement
des infirmières, des aides soignants, des médecins.. J'enseigne à la fac de médecine à la Pitié, les trois-quarts de médecins seront des femmes
90% dans les écoles veto aujourd'hui
donc ça veut dire qu'effectivement il ya des choses qui sont très intéressants à se pencher dessus au niveau social
pour voir comment ça se passe bien évidemment
donc ces mouvements là oui ils sont la résultante de la non prise en compte de leur existence
aussi je dois le reconnaître d'une espèce d'arrogance vis-à-vis d'eux et puis aussi bien sûr
du fait que
il s'était peu exprimé
jusque là et puis après les mouvements vont dégénéré parce qu'on va faire croire aux gens que plus on est violent mieux ça marche
j'y crois pas non plus beaucoup donc c'est vrai que
c'est pas ça des fois on arrivera ce que dira jancovici donc jusqu'au démarrage du mouvement il dira d'un côté c'est la fin du mois
et enfin c'est la fin du monde
et ça c'est terrible parce que la fin du mois elle revient tous les mois
et quand il revient tous les mois on oublie la fin du monde la fin du monde aujourd'hui on a dit c'était
le changement climatique accéléré
l'effondrement des vivants qui amène je vous l'ai expliquer la genèse de ces maladies pandémiques avec ce petit covid 19
Donc au départ ça je vous l'avais montré aussi donc lui on part sur de
l'ancestrale donc du monde minéral cette météorite elle raconte l'histoire de la terre puisqu'elle tombe dans un champ à Toulouse
en mai 1864
Et c'est là que c'est génial parce qu'un paysan la ramasse
Souvent on me demande "mais c'est quoi la différence entre un humain et un animal ?"
Aucun animal n'aurait ramassé la météorite d'Orgueil, ce petit village du Tarn et Garonne, jamais, il l'a ramassée il s'est brûlé avec ce
paysan
c'est génial, il n'y à qu'un humain qui fait ça pourquoi il l'a ramassé "c'est bizarre, il s'est passé un truc je la ramasse, je me brule"
Et puis il l'a met dans une caisse à oignon et elle passe 120 ans dans une caisse à oignon dans le jardin
On la retrouve en 2005
Et elle va finir devant les plus puissants outils de géochimie qu'on ait à paris
et dans le monde, ça s'appelle des nanosondes rue Buffon à paris et on la date
4,6
milliards d'années ce caillou est contemporain de la mise en place du Soleil et de la Terre
Quand vous le caresser ça change tout, vous avez le palpitant..
c'est moche comme tout
Là depuis avant-hier, venez à paris voir la collection fabuleuse, qu'on représente avec Van Cleef & Arpels, de gemmes
vous verrez le diamant bleu la copie de diamant bleu Louis XIV c'est tellement c'est beau à pleurer à tomber par terre
ça c'est moche comme tout !
mais ça nous permet de raconter une histoire
incroyablement plus exceptionnel l'histoire de la terre et l'apparition de la vie un peu plus tard dessus il y à 4 milliards et demi d'années
et la vie vers à peu près un peu moins de 4 milliards d'années 4000 millions d'années la vie apparait sur la Terre
donc c'est vrai que ça va changer, l'océan est très stable sa composition est resté au moins la même depuis cent millions d'années
et puis bien sûr on va passer ici de l'eau douce il y avait des fleuves et des rivières, l'eau de mer ici. Et ça c'est quoi ?
Ca je vous l'avais raconté aussi, et bien ça c'est votre sang en ce moment je vous l'avais dit
pourquoi est ce que votre sang en ce moment c'est ça
un estuaire ce n'est ni de l'eau douce ni de l'eau de mer c'est votre sang, pourquoi ?
vous regarderez avec amour votre prochaine prise de sang vous regarderez, vous verrez 140 millimole de sodium, vous vérifierez je raconte pas de crack
et 105 millimole de chlorure tous ici dans la salle garçon/fille jeunes vieux beau pas beau
142 millimole de sodium c'est comme ça depuis que la terre tourne depuis qu'à des humains sur la terre
Simplement c'est la trace ancestrale de l'apparition de la vie dans l'océan l'humain la raconte à travers son sang
Et ça c'est intéressant c'est l'eau saumâtre d'un estuaire, quand la vilaine se jette à Arzal là c'est comme ça
la gironde aussi bien sur
près de bordeaux c'est la même chose donc c'est intéressant parce que ça raconte des histoires
Et si on ne connait pas le passé on a du mal à imaginer l'avenir
Ici vous avez le plus ancien fossile que l'on ait à Paris, des cyanobactéries
daté à 3,45 milliards d'années, elles viennent d'Australie
et ça c'est les mêmes que j'ai ramassé tout à l'heure je suis allé faire un excellent dîner tout à l'heure la
avec Maëtte et avec Michel il y a une flaque d'eau, vous verrez en sortant tout à l'heure
dans cette flaque d'eau il ya des cyanobactéries comme celle là
C'est les même. Elles ont presque 4 milles
millions d'années l'histoire évolutive différents elles sont toujours là
je sais pas s'il ya des chefs d'entreprise ici dans la salle
Le rêve d'un chef d'entreprise, c'est une entreprise durable "je vais durer,  je suis bon je fais attention je veux gagner des sous"
en durant longtemps
Il n'y a rien de mieux que la vie la plus belle entreprise qui ait jamais existé sur la planète et la vie
4 milliards d'années des milliards d'êtres vivants différents il nous reste peut-être 2% aujourd'hui
Et on s'en occupe pas on a oublié qu'on ait fait de bactéries un bébé humain à la naissance trois quarts d'eau
c'est pas fait pour laver sa bagnole
laissez la pluie Rennaise laver les voitures
Donc ça veut dire qu'un bébé humain qui nait au moment de la rupture de la poche des eaux il y à des mamans je suppose dans
dans la salle et c'est qu'ils ont eu des bébés ou des papas qui ont assisté à l'accouchement
c'est fantastique à ce moment là les bactéries du tractus de la maman se précipitent pour aller on dit contaminer, ensemencer ce bébé
Ce bébé à vir il va installer sa fleur à lui que à lui et qu'est-ce que cible le coronavirus
Ah c'est super intéressant pour moi, il cible les gens qui justement ont perdu le dialogue entre leurs cellules humaines
et ces bactéries qui sont symbiote dans ce corps c'est l'obésité c'est de diabète de type 2
c'est alzheimer c'est l'autisme
c'est aussi le manque d'activité physique est très important là dedans aussi
c'est l'hypertension artérielle
qu'est-ce qu'il a tué le coronavirus ? La moyenne des gens qui sont morts c'est 81 ans en Europe
Vous savez que la durée de vie des femmes en France c'est 84 en ce moment des garçons c'est 80
Donc il tue des gens qui n'étaient pas loin de la fin de l'espérance de vie
Ils tuent des gens 84%
obèses
les trois-quarts diabète de type 2, hypertension artérielle
tous ces gens ne faisait plus d'activité physique depuis longtemps, la malbouffe
Manger moins beaucoup mieux payer un peu plus cher ce que vous mangez
c'est tellement important pour vous on est le reflet de ce qu'on mange
d'ailleurs demain si on arrête
de mal payé le monde agricole en achetant de la bouffe qui vaut rien du tout mais qui vaut rien
Si on commence demain à payer correctement nos produits agricoles y aura plus de pesticides on réglera beaucoup de nos problèmes aujourd'hui on voyait que
tout ça est très très lié c'est compliqué à comprendre pour un homme politique il a du mal à s'en sortir
tout est lié en fait les effet papillon vous vous rappelez à
l'époque en disant que si on touche à ça ici ça va affecter autre chose
c'est très important dans ces questions là, en tous cas la Covid 19
tuent des gens qui déjà était en énorme majorité en détresse physiologique
D'abord il tue peu, 85% des gens n'ont aucuns symptômes même pas un rhume ni rien
Dans ceux qui sont malades après différents grad ations mais ceux qui vont  en mourir
sont des gens à au dessus de à 80 90 % qui déjà auparavant avait des problèmes physiologiques
Voilà bon l'eau, ça c'est Atacama
c'est le désert le plus sec de la planète il ne pleut jamais, il n'a pas plu depuis la conquête espagnole
et tous les 12 ou 15 ans sur la périphérie du désert
lors d'un phénomène "el niño" le  niño en castellanos c'est le christ jésus
à noël el niño c'est ça et ce phénomène se produit effectivement en fin d'année il fait que les vents s'inverse dans le pacifique sud
et là où il ne pleut jamais il se met à pleuvoir
et là où effectivement il pleut il ne pleut plus
parce que la température change et on voit les vents qui vont souffler d'Indonésie vers les côtes d'Amérique du sud là
En général c'est l'inverse bien sûr
et regarder ce qui se passe à ce moment là voilà ça ça s'appelle le désert fleurie c'est le miracle de la vie
si je met de l'eau dans le désert
alors vous imaginez mais pour que ça se passe en trois semaines
tout était déjà là les graines sont là, elles attendent depuis 20 ans, elles attendent un peu d'eau
et là l'humain peut s'amuser à jouer au dieu, ici au Soudan
on va capter le Nil c'est le fleuve qui est là et puis amener l'eau dans le désert et créer du vivant
donc c'est vrai que l'eau est tellement importante
ici dans ce pays qu'est la Bretagne a massacré notre eau on l'a souillé on l'a gaspillé
ça c'est épouvantable nos anciens ne faisait pas du tout rappelez-vous toutes les mythologies
religieuse ou pas lié aux fontaines en bretagne la fontaine elle était magique
on en prenait soin mais comme à la prunelle de ses yeux on savait très bien que c'était la vie de la petite
tribu la petite commune le petit village qui était là. Et puis après on a fait d'énormes systèmes on sait même pas d'où vient l'eau que l'on
boit
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant on dilue la pollution
tel département est vraiment très mauvaise qualité on va diluer avec celui de la côte est qu un peu moins bon qu'avec un peu meilleures
pour faire un équilibre entre les deux comment voulez vous vous intéressez à l'eau quand vous faites des systèmes qui sont comme ça
donc c'est là que c'est tellement tellement important pour nous je veux montrer des images juste après
c'est tellement facile pour nous ici à Rennes on ouvre le robinet en anneau d'aller voir c'est pas le cas de tout le monde
donc l'eau est vraiment essentielle avant l'ADN la molécule du vivant
c'est l'eau, c'est l'eau toutes les cellules vivantes sont fait d'eau liquide c'est pour ça que la vie est sur la terre
Voilà aujourd'hui ça on l'avait calculé au moment de la coop 21 toutes ces jeunes femmes africaines
ça c'est simplement le nombre d'heures de travail en plus ce qu'elles vont faire
40 milliards
d'heures de travail pour ces jeunes filles simplement "collecting water" aller chercher de l'eau
ici on n'a aucune idée de ce que c'est elles font 15 km 30 km 40 km avec un bidon
chinois de plastique sur la tête vingt fois je me suis arrêté mesurer le volume de ces bidons 17 litres 17 kg
sur un vélo sur la tête entre les bras on va chercher de l'eau
et quand vous faites ça le drame épouvantable pour ces jeunes filles elles ne vont pas à l'école
Et puis la démographie on arrive à 8 milliards d'humains j'aime bien les chiffres je vous disais à température
1945 Hiroshima on est 2 milliards d'humain sur la Terre on arrive à 8, on a dépassé 7,9
On a quadruplé la population humaine sur soixante dix ans donc c'est considérable bien évidemment vous imaginez bien
et c'est vrai que cette histoire de l'eau elle est absolument essentiel elles ne vont pas à l'école
il ya une coupe qui marche très bien plus vous éduquez une jeune fille moins elle fait de mêmes, ça c'est clair
Là écoutez.. Elles ne vont pas à l'école elles ne
sont jamais propriétaire des terrains sur lesquels elles travaillent et elles sont paysannes ces femmes c'est pas elles ça appartient à un mec
troisièmement elles n'ont jamais de salaire pour faire ça on les paye pas les filles africaines
puis pour terminer l'horreur on fait de mauvaises rencontres en route parce que les gamins à 14 ans des kalachnikovs chinoises
50 $ une kalach au soudan au congo
vous pouvez en acheter tous les jours si vous voulez toutes les munitions que vous voulez sont en Afrique aujourd'hui
Et donc elles se font violer en permanence, elles reviennent féconder en plus quand elles vont chercher de l'eau on voyait que
ça s'est tellement tellement important c'est de l'écologie de base
si on prend si on ne tient pas compte de ça on s'en sortira pas non plus la seule façon de gérer les questions d'immigration
c'est qu'ils ne partent pas parce qu'ils sont bien chez eux
donc il faut qu'on les aide massivement à être bien chez eux, nous on peut  accueillir un petit peu mais pas être défini mon c'est très très
bien quels que soient les idées qu'on peut avoir là-dessus c'est évident ce qu'il faut c'est toujours humain dans des conditions de
regard sur ce qui se passe sauver des gens immédiatement oui mais qu'est ce qu'on en fait comment on fait avec eux
donc simplement les aider à être bien chez eux quand je parle avec eux ils n'ont pas du tout envie de partir de chez eux
vous n'avez pas envie de partir de Rennes
quel est notre problème finalement si on va jusqu'au bout ici tous dans la salle est alors ici il ya des gens qui sont
employés des chefs d'entreprise ya de tout
des hommes des femmes
de bonne volonté, qui ont envie de vivre à Rennes je suppose que si vous êtes là c'est que vous êtes ça vous fait plaisir d'être là
sinon vous seriez partis ailleurs
et bien la seule question vous êtes heureux d'être ici
vous avez une famille des enfants peut-être des petits enfants pour beaucoup d'entre vous vous avez créé de l'emploi j'admire beaucoup ça il y à un tissu économique
mais à une seule condition
de faire ça sans détruire
l'endroit dans lequel vous habitez et c'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
voilà le gros problème en ce moment que l'on a c'est qu'on détruit les endroits dans lequel on habite
on a dit la pollution de l'eau on a dit
la remontée du niveau de la mer on a dit un emploi trop important de pesticides donc c'est vrai que
là on pêche des poissons, prendre des grands thons c'est magnifique de manger du thon mais n'en mangez pas trop souvent ils sont bourrés de
méthylmercure
ça c'est bien une influence humaine donc vous pouvez en manger une fois toutes les semaines mais n'aller manger des sushis tous les jours de
thons ni d'espadon
Ca relance le débat sur
effectivement ce qu'on est, ce qu'on fait les problèmes de développement du cerveau des enfants en relation avec des produits toxiques
qui se trouve aujourd'hui dans les sols ou dans l'atmosphère ou dans les cours d'eau c'est très important à regarder
ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on revienne à des vraies valeurs qui sont les nôtres en fait comment est ce qu'on fait
pour effectivement créé une bonne activité économique
pas au détriment bien sûr par la destruction de l'endroit dans lequel on est ou pire que ça
on détruit pas l'endroit dans lequel on habite ont détruit les endroits ailleurs parce qu'on va acheter notre soja au brésil en
découpant en morceau la forêt tropicale amazonienne
donc ça il faut qu'on y songe en permanence
encore une fois c'est pas des punitions c'est pas une contrainte épouvantable et de se dire voilà
je suis le reflet de ce que je mange je suis le reflet du type de vie que j'ai choisi j'échange avec d'autres
je suis heureux d'être là
donc prenons le critère du bonheur je vous disais l'an derniert je vous disais mais depuis ce matin tout ce que vous avez fait
qui sert à rien mais a rien du tout
mais qui vous a apporté du plaisir et du bonheur ou est-ce qu'on comptabilise ça dans quelle échelle c'est pas un produit intérieur brut
qui va vous donner donner quelque chose là dessus
c'est pas des critères économiques classiques là on est dans les scènes terribles d'économie où tout est effectivement au profit économique
eh ben ça c'est fini et c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on prenne en considération
au travers de l'alerte de la petite Covid que je vais développer
Voilà une goutte d'eau de mer c'est ça depuis depuis les origines de la vie 4 milliards d'années
les grosses taches jaunes sont des protistes les moyens taches jaunes ce sont des bactéries
et les tout petits points sont des virus une goutte d'eau de mer où que vous allez c'est comme ça partout partout partout partout
et ça fait 98% ça de la biomasse de l'océan et les poissons et les baleines c'est que 2%
ça c'est 13% des espèces connaît sur la terre aujourd'hui
Un sol, je suppose qu'il y a des gens du monde agricole ici dans la salle moi je les aime beaucoup
Voilà un sol vivant, vivant !
2 tonne 5 de bactéries à l'hectare 3,35 des micro champignons
des collemboles des acariens des nématodes des vers de terre des tardigrades.
C'est ça un sol vivant. On a tué la moitié de nos sols.
Par nature
productiviste autant d'ailleurs j'avais vu autant d'ailleurs la mécanisation
que les questions de pesticide il n'y a pas que les pesticides
de reprendre ses sols en permanence de les aérer et tout ces très mauvais et surtout ne laissez jamais un sol nu
Un sol nu c'est une cata
ramené de la matière organique dans les sols
Ce qui veut dire qu'au niveau du monde agricole c'est très simple pour moi quand je discute avec eux tous maintenant ils commencent à l'admettre j'ai
pas d'ennemis là dessus tous sont d'accord
ramenons de la matière organique dans les sols et de la vie dans les sols on ne produira pas
à manger pour 8 milliards d'humains si on ne ramène pas de la vie dans les sols puis demain 9 milliards donc c'est
essentiel ça c'est deux fois plus espèces connues que dans l'océan vous imaginez l'importance de nos sols, ici en Bretagne
un sol, ce n'est pas épais un sol c'est comme ça c'est comme ça hein après on est rapidement sur l'arène ici donc c'est tellement tellement important
puis de temps en temps un petit coquelicot c'est sympa
c'est pas le but du paysan de faire des coquelicots mais quand vous faites 200 km en bretagne sans avoir un seul coquelicot
Bah y à rien en dessous prenez un peu de terre, sentez là
en beauce ou en brie par exemple on parle beaucoup des terres à céréales en ce moment
il n'y a plus rien donc ça veut dire que là il faut vraiment revenir en arrière il faudrait un petit peu de temps
dépolluer et ramener de la vie dans ces sols mais c'est jouable avec le monde agricole bien sûr évidemment pas contre eux
troisième écosystème et dernier, c'est un bébé justement j'aime bien les bébés aussi ça c'est l'intestin d'un bébé à la naissance
voyez qu'il est quasi vide de bactéries
ça c'est des bactéries de l'utérus de la maman qui se précipitent pour aller contaminer ce bébé au moment de la naissance
ça c'est l'océan la manip tara avec Tara Océan dont par les micro algues qu'on a séquencé, qu'on a trouvé
on double le nombre d'espèces connues 600000 séquence ramenée entre 2009 et 2013, inconnues auparavant, on connaissait pas ça
des dinoflagellés, des diatomées, des coccolithophoridés et les micro algues de l'océan, des gros protistes
et puis ben voilà en bleu là je vous ai mis effectivement des gènes de ces microalgues
en orange sur les gènes du bébé là
et en gris c'est notre génome à nous ça je vous l'avais dit aussi ça veut dire que nous avons tous ici dans la salle
un tiers de nos gènes en commun avec des algues, du plancton, on vient du même monde
on appartient au même monde
Le but de cette entrée en matière et je la raconte souvent c'est
je veux vous persuader d'une chose vraiment fondamentale, si je réussi ça j'ai gagné ce soir
persuadez vous que nous sommes le vivant et la biodiversité
chaque fois que vous allez l'agresser vous vous auto agressé
C'est un peu stupide pour une espèce qui elle même s'est appelée sapiens : l'homme sage
Regardez tout ce qui se passe en ce moment on est vraiment pas sage du tout en fait on n'est pas savant
on a oublié
les choses mais tellement essentielles et ça il faut le raconter aux enfants à l'école maternelle
Je suis en gros conflit en ce moment avec  ce gouvernement sur l'enseignement puisqu'ils sont en train de nous tuer
dans les lycées l'enseignement des sciences de la vie de la terre
Demain ça sera un math physique où lettre, c'est du délire complet j'ai rien contre les lettres et les math, physique
mais alors elles sont où les sciences de la terre est les sciences de la vie elles sont complètement oubliés en fait c'est dramatique ça
donc voilà et ça c'est votre lit ce matin ça je vous l'avait raconté je me souviens
voilà c'est votre lit ce matin voilà qu'est ce qui est plus intime que votre lit dites moi
on ouvre œil "oh je reste encore un peu" "y a école aujourd'hui aie aie aie aie.. Ah non c'est samedi c'est bien je reste encore un petit
peu là on va voir comment ça se passe" alors en plus mon truc que vous dormez tout seul ou à deux ça marche mon histoire
vous avez chaque matin dans votre lit parce que vous y avez dormi entre 1 et 2 millions d'acariens
voilà, qu'est ce qu'ils font ? Bah écoutez ils sont contents d'être là ils bouffent vos poils vos cheveux
toutes les cellules de la peau qui se sont desquamer pendant la nuit, vous avez frottez vos draps.. Et puis c'est comme ça
ce qui veut dire que vraiment on est en permanence
quand on me dit mais ta biodiversité c'est l'histoire des écolos mais non pas du tout c'est nous tous
C'est ça la biodiversité finalement et souvent je montre toujours l'image qui vient après
ça c'est le plancton quand on a fait Tara on a pu démontrer en fait que dans l'océan depuis les origines
de la vie il y a infiniment plus
de coopération que de compétition
quand vous voyez en ce moment par exemple Christophe André qui est un des grands penseurs
de la méditation actuel qui dit en fait la coopération permet au maximum de survivre la compétition permet à quelques-uns de survivre
à terme si on va vers une harmonie si on va non pas le monde est totalement
tout le monde au même niveau c'est pour ça que en plus au niveau ça veut dire quoi jeudi la capacité de chacun de s'exprimer
avec ses propres possibilités dans un monde dans lequel il est
et comprendre aussi que chaque fois que il commence à gêner le voisin et bah c'est les limites
il n'y a pas que les humains sur la terre, il y à les humains et puis il y a
2 4 milliards d'espèces vivantes connues avec nous ils ont leur place
nos nématode tout à l'heure nos acarien de notre lit ils ont leur place sur la Terre
en vertu de quoi on irait nous dire "j'en ai rien à faire je ne m'occupe plus"
ça c'est intéressant parce que quand on dit à un entrepreneur ce qu'on appelle darwinisme social c'est totalement débile darwin n'a jamais dit ça
manger l'entreprise d'à côté surtout pas
coopérer avec dans une saine coopération avec des problèmes de choses que je comprends très bien de choses qui sont gardées secrètes pour une entreprise
il faut innover en permanence, pour innover, ça demande de faire des efforts qui sont rémunérés pour une entreprise bien évidemment
Voilà c'est ça la biodiversité
Qu'est-ce que nous serions tous dans la salle si allez soyez honnête avec moi deux minutes
comment vivriers vous sans le fromage le pinard et le pain
on va me dire moi je bois pas d'alcool moi je mange pas de
si j'enlève le nickel découvert ici et puis effectivement le verre des bouteilles c'est que ça
et c'est notre vie tous les jours depuis les origines de l'humain qui bouffe ce qu'il trouvait l'humain est profondément
omnivore au démarrage si Lucy avait pas manger un peu de viande et les
néandertaliens on serait pas là où ça veut dire que par contre ce qui est clair c'est qu'il faut en manger beaucoup moins aujourd'hui
ça c'est sûr
23 milliards de poulet sur la terre
1,3 milliard de vaches il ya plus de biomasse de vaches de biomasse d'humains vous voyez que
on sent un peu encore une fois c'est comme 100000 avions par jour c'est la mesure qu'on a plus du tout en tête
on est dans la démesure en permanence on est dans une fuite en avant sans arrêt plus plus plus plus de cupidité incroyable
c'est pour ça a pris dans l'extrémisme dire "ouais mais tu es pas contre les avions contre la consommation de viande"
la question n'est pas là c'est un petit peu oui
mais dans la mesure dans le plaisir deux chiffres encore
il ya 140 ans ici à rennes la consommation moyenne est de 1500 kcal par jour
On a 3000 aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup trop 3000 pour une femme qui bouge pas or bah les gens après comment ils sont évidemment hein
Et la Covid les cible ces gens là bien évidemment
donc c'est vrai que
non seulement on en mange trop en kilocalories mais en plus on bouffe mal
et c'est une chose qui me hérisse le poil depuis longtemps dans ce pays parce qu'on est pauvre on doit malbouffer et
ça c'est pas possible c'est pas une démocratie
donc ça relance tout le débat sur le coût des produits alors
payer un tout petit peu plus cher son alimentation oui je suis pour parce que c'est tellement important plus que le dernier écrans plats ou
le dernier téléphone portable ou la voiture un peu plus puissante non le vrai truc c'est manger bien, moins,
dans des bonnes conditions et en vraie convivialité avec sa famille avec qui vous voulez bien évidemment c'est tellement important
et c'est quand ceux-ci ne marche pas que la Covid aussi va taper je vous rappelle les fantasmes des français
ça a été publié partout le lendemain du déconfinement deux fantasmes aller chez le coiffeur
et aller chez mcdo voilà comprenez pourquoi des fois j'ai du mal à accepter que j'appartiens à la même espèce que ces gens là quoi
mais je suis sûr que vous êtes comme moi
Sinon vous ne seriez pas venu m'écouter
donc les vaches effectivement la vache c'est bien mais y en à beaucoup trop
Et ces livres sont magnifiques de Marc-André Selosse, je sais pas si il est venu à Rennes déjà Marc-André ben voilà j'adore ce personnage
et il nous dit en fait un arbre il n'est jamais seul
et puis à corps humain c'est tous entrelacés on est tellement un entrelacs d'êtres vivants
dont nos sur nos cellules humaines on n'a pas une cellule différente des globules rouges des neurones des cellules du foie
les hépatocytes des cellules des poumons, tout comme le Coronavirus,
les cheveux tout ce que vous voulez, les muscles
les adipocytes
tout ça oui
mais en intime coopération avec d'autres organismes qui vivent avec
et dialoguent entre eux en permanence
Voilà ça c'était l'image un peu symbolique de l'humain il y a trente-sept mille ans a Chauvet
capable de faire ça qui dessine comme ça
Et surtout la question pourquoi ils ont fait ça
franchement dans la vie de tous les jours ça sert à rien, je fais exprès d'être provocateur
s'ils l'ont fait ça veut dire que ça servait à quelque chose, ça sert à rien vous courrez pas plus vite vous sauterez pas plus haut
mais c'est génial en fait parce que bien sûr c'est à chamanisme qui est très important il dessine la biodiversité
qui n'est pas devant eux ils sont au fond d'une grotte à 300 mètres de l'entrée
l'antilope, ils l'ont vu 15 jours avant, il y avait des lions en France
il y avait des hyènes, il y avait des panthères à ce moment là, il y avait des rhinocéros
Donc s'ils ont pu faire ça il y a 37.. C'est deux fois plus que Lascaux, Lascaux c'est 20000
pourquoi on ferait pas mieux aujourd'hui avec les moyens que l'on a effectivement par rapport aux soucis que l'on rencontre aujourd'hui c'est la vraie question
c'est Jean Marie Chauvet ici qui était avec ses amis
Christian Hillaire et Eliette Brunel qui découvre cette grotte le 19 décembre
1994 j'ai eu la chance d'aller deux fois voir l'original, vous en pleurez à chaque fois
Voilà c'est la dernière courbe du début ça c'est comment l'humain a évolué en nombre de personne humaine ici
on était 5 millions il y a dix mille ans on s'arrête de bouger ici en bretagne on a beaucoup travaillé en Bretagne sur le passage
de ce qu'on appelle les chasseurs cueilleurs aux passeurs agriculteurs et sur les îles c'est super intéressant les îles du Morbihan
puisqu'il pouvait y aller, à certaines saisons qu'est ce qu'ils mangeaient la coquille saint jacques
ou une brinic, une bernique comme on dit en Bretagne
on arrive, selon l'endroit où on la retrouve, on arrive à savoir à quelle température de l'eau elle a existé
quand il la mange, c'est génial on voit qu'ils étaient là que l'hiver, chassant sur de telles iles, comment ils faisaient et on voit une
l'arrivée en fait de
de passeurs agriculteurs qui arrivent effectivement de l'est ici on peut arriver que de l'est
et qui vont petit à petit éliminer les populations de chasseurs cueilleurs, qui vont partir donc qui vont disparaître
et c'est très intéressant la Bretagne pour.. A Rennes ici c'est un jeu un joli site pour faire ça toute une équipe
d'archéologie à l'université rennes travaille là-dessus. Donc vous voyez que bah on va multiplier les humains
5 millions et puis voilà et aujourd'hui on a dit 8 milliards. Il y à deux fois où ça a régressé
Les pestes noire, la grippe espagnole
Au départ on avait que ça
d'ailleurs dans le monde agricole ici, mes amis paysans le savent on retrouve plein de bifaces dans les sols
un biface c'est un bout de caillou taillé
de trois millions d'années jusqu'à
Deux mille ans ça c'est toujours fait, en fait
Aller voir le grand cairn de Barnenez, vous connaissez près de Morlaix ? Le cairn mégalithique de Barnenez en Plouezoc'h
C'est la plus ancienne construction de cette taille là connu au monde on est on est avant les prémices de l'Egypte 4500 avant
Onze domaines à couloirs qui sont accolés, il y a des bifaces ça veut dire que
effectivement cet outil qui servait d'outil et d'arme on avait que ça à l'époque
bon on faisait tout avec ça, on grattait, on taillait, on perçait..
On cognait sur un animal, on tapait sur le copain ou la copine
Mais c'était du corps à corps
et tout va changer au moment où l'humain va inventer l'arme de jet, tout va changer il y a 8000 ans
L'arc et la flèche et ça, ça change tout
et les animaux qui étaient les grands prédateurs des humains vont commencer à avoir peur de ce petit machin tout mouillé qui fait 40 kg
au départ on était Africain,
noirs, poilus. Tous on était comme ça, ça ne plaît pas à certains mais c'est comme ça
l'humain est profondément Africain nous sommes tous des Africains
Quand quelqu'un dira un jour que l'homme Africain n'a pas d'histoire je vous raconte pas
comme connerie on ne peut pas dire beaucoup plus pires que ça
Sans eux on ne serait pas là c'est toute l'histoire de l'humanité c'est tout s'est passé comme ça ils sortent d'Afrique.
Ils sortent d'Afrique chaque fois que le Sahara n'est plus un désert tous les dix mille, douze mille ans, il pleut dans le Sahara,
la péninsule arabique redevient verte et on sort de l'Afrique et on vient en Europe on vient en Bretagne
et chez les populations là on a des populations là oui.. Menez-Dregan en baie d'Audierne c'est 400 milles
C'est équivalent de Tautavel c'est donc des..
Des heidelbergensis, des erectus. on est avant nehenderthal encore
sur ces gisements là, on n'a pas de traces d'ossement parce qu'ils se conservent très mal en Bretagne, les sol acides ici
Par contre, on a des traces d'activités humaines, des foyers par exemple.. Menez-Dregan 400000, bon Tautavel
dans les Corbières, c'est le fond de la grotte à 700000 donc c'est les plus anciens Français qui existent en fait 700 mille ans.
Mais en Espagne on a des gisements à Burgos à deux millions
La Sima de los Huesos près de Burgos, c'est un million huit
7 espèces d'humain qui se succèdent sur deux millions d'années en fait sur le site de
de los Huesos et puis aujourd'hui, il n'y à plus que sapiens tous les humains actuels sur un inter fécond
c'est comme ça
les petits, les grands, les moyens, les cheveux noirs, les cheveux blonds, on est tous interféconds, il ne reste plus qu'une espèce aujourd'hui
Et on invente la route vers sept milles ans puis après ça, ça va être une terrible invention, la poudre noire qui va tout
changer puisque avec ça c'est tellement facile.
N'importe quel olibrius il appuie sur une détente et il tue un éléphant, il tue une girafe, il tue..
tout ce que vous voulez. Quand je vois ces gamins aujourd'hui à la frontière du Congo et du Soudan qui ont tous des kalachnikovs, qui flinguent tout..
Ils ont violé toutes les filles du village d'à côté. C'est vrai que
ces inventions, comme disait Edgar Morin, c'est pas tellement la frénésie de découvertes scientifiques et technologiques qui pose problème c'est
l'usage que l'on en fait et la Covid 19 est vraiment là pour nous le rappeler en permanence en fait
Vous vouez les âges des métaux, la domestication animal à l'époque bien sûr.
Et puis après ça va être les moulins à eau avant, la poudre noire, les vaccins, les avions, les matières plastiques
les antibiotiques, les ordinateurs et tout ça explose l'énorme explosion de la population humaine.
Aujourd'hui quand vous regardez, la courbe s'aplanit un petit peu, les Indiens par exemple, ils sont 2,3 milliards en Inde. En chine aussi
la moyenne d'enfants par femme en Inde c'est pas tellement c'est 2,3
nous on est à 1,9 en France donc c'est un petit peu plus, ça a beaucoup beaucoup baissé
Le pays où c'est encore le plus par femme c'est le Niger en ce moment, c'est encore sept à huit
enfants par femme. Mais elle ne décide pas les femmes, on revient à ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure en fait, elles ne vont pas l'école les petites
Vous voyez que
c'est vraiment de l'écologie de terrain extrêmement importante dans tout ça, la vraie écologie
la science écologique, et donc aujourd'hui Darwin, Malthus on en parle souvent
Donc voilà ça c'est la question de base : est ce qu'on est en train de créer les conditions de nouvelles crises d'extinctions ?
Parce que en fait ce qu'on fait c'est que on détruit et on pollue
on surexploite
On dissémine tout partout et le climat change trop vite.
Et bien sûr il faut être de très mauvaise foi pour dire que l'homme n'y est pour rien, voilà. Qu'est ce qu'on fait demain ?
A la lumière de la Covid dont on va parler maintenant, pour arranger un peu la situation.
Voilà la courbe un peu dur que j'ai à vous montrer ce soir. Donc c'est l'effondrement du vivant, en vert c'est le vivant sauvage
Tous les vertébrés sauvages
En bleu, animaux domestiques
les vaches, les cochons, les poulets, les chèvres, les chevaux
les moutons, les chiens et les chats
c'est une explosion du nombre d'individus et en rouge ce sont les humains vous voyez que
la vraie question c'est quelle place on laisse aux autres en fait c'est ça
nous consommons nous humains avec nos animaux domestiques
la moitié de l'eau disponible sur la Terre donc les 2,4 millions d'espèces en plus elles n'ont que la moitié de l'eau à se
distribuer en fait alors c'est intéressant parce que l'eau c'est pas quelque chose qui va disparaître
Il y à une quantité d'eau sur la terre qu'on connaît bien, arroser un champ agricole vous arrosez votre champ, l'eau elle n'est pas perdue.
Le problème c'est
effectivement, l'existence de l'eau dans un endroit précis un moment précis
on sait que sans eau, il n'y a pas d'agriculture par exemple, ça c'est très important la déforestation en Afrique
le changement climatique amène à des zones en train de devenir des déserts complet
et un désert complet, on aura pas de paysans ils pourront pas rester il n'y a pas d'eau.
On peut dans un système agricole supporter une année un peu sèche mais pas trois, quatre, cinq, dix ans, c'est pas possible.
Beaucoup de grandes civilisations se sont éteintes comme ça parce qu'on est restés 12, 13, 14 ans sans pluie ou pratiquement pas. Vous voyez que
c'est extrêmement important et le monde agricole le sait bien, bien sûr.
Voilà donc comment la politique le reprend, là on criait effectivement : "si on fait rien il sera trop tard !" quinze mille scientifiques
novembre 2017, ça c'est le papier qui a bouleversé ma vie.
Je lisais ce papier en 2001 disant : "Le plus puissant moteur de changement sur la terre c'est la présence de l'humain".
Le président Macron vient d'être élu donc il est tout feu tout flamme, il cri à la tribune  du conseil mondial
à l'île Seguin le 12 décembre 2017 c'est à dire deux ans après la COP 21 :
"Nous ne prenons pas le chemin financier de réussir l'accord de Paris" et puis nous on réagit effectivement
le monde réagit après le travail fait par la l'IPBS
le 9 mai
2019 il n'est pas trop tard, mais chaque fois , chaque minute qui passe nous rapproche d'échéances terribles. On ne sait pas la fixer.
C'est à dire qu'il faut se dépêcher tout de suite il fallait commencer hier, avant-hier
Puis qu'on arrête d'en parler tout le temps partout si on fait rien
je comprends moi l'impatience et je dirais même la colère des jeunes
qui nous disent mais vous n'en faites pas assez, écoutez-les, ils crient partout
Nos étudiantes, beaucoup de filles en plus, en veto, en agro,
études médicales, en écologie à Jussieu elles disent toutes la même chose, j'ai trois quarts du fille maintenant en médecine
90% en école véto tout à l'heure je vous disais, trois quarts dans les écoles d'agronome
qu'est ce qu'elles nous disent ces jeunes femmes elles ont 21 ans, 22 ans, elles nous disent "écoutez c'est pas possible".
Vous savez ce qu'elles me disent, ce qui me fait le plus mal : "Nous n'aurons pas d'enfant"
Ca c'est notre échec à nous, je suis désolé, moi à 20 ans j'étais amoureux j'avais envie d'avoir un bébé
donc pourquoi est ce que nous par nos comportements
on a créé une situation qui les amène
A une certaine désespérance, une jeune femme qui a envie d'avoir un bébé pourquoi pas, pourquoi pas un garçon aussi d'ailleurs
c'est très important mais je comprends
Il y à un papier est sorti en janvier cette année qui dit voilà ceux des médecins qu'elle écrit ça
quel sera l'avis d'un gamin qui naît le 1er janvier 2020
ça ne donne pas envie d'en faire. Quand il fera à paris en 2045 54 degrés pendant deux semaines et la Seine sera à sec
mais c'est pas des histoires en fait d'écolo farfelu encore une fois il faut que tous on prenne ça
en considération encore une fois pas par la terreur je ne veux pas créer de l'éco-anxiété, surtout chez les jeunes
je suis vraiment l'ennemi des collapsologues, j'aime pas du tout ça
Le collapsologue il dit "c'est foutu', non c'est pas du tout foutu mais il faut qu'on réagisse c'est très très important ça c'est très
très important
Voilà donc l'IPBS ai réunis c'est l'équivalent de l'IPCC climat mais pour la biodiversité
et ils font leur rapport il y a juste un an c'était le 9 mai
"La nature décline globalement à un rythme sans précédent dans l'histoire humaine.
Nous sommes en train d'éroder les fondements mêmes de nos économies,
nos moyens de subsistance, la sécurité alimentaire, la santé et la qualité de la vie dans le monde entier." Ben voilà
c'est ça aussi qui a laissé passer la Covid 19
Alors, voilà le rapport des Nations Unies, il y a quinze jours, c'est tout récent  ils vont faire une réunion à
la fin du mois de septembre
la santé des écosystèmes dont nous dépendons ainsi que toutes les autres espèces se dégrade plus vite que jamais
donc ça c'est très très important.
Le rapport donc contient pleins de recommandations. Vous pourrez le lire, c'est sur internet je l'ai récupéré hier
La conception des villes est proposée comment les écosystèmes peuvent être restaurés conservés
Tout ça bien sûr dans un monde où il nous faut produire
Nous sommes de plus en plus nombreux
il faut pas augmenter les surfaces agricoles
indéfiniment. Sinon bah moi je perds mes zones humides, je fais exprès de parler en mon nom, et je perds effectivement mes forêts tropicales humides
Produire plus
avec pas plus de surface, ça veut dire qu'il faut aller vers l'intensification mais sans la chimie, c'est jouable.
Le seul système qui sait faire passer c'est l'agroécologie
c'est les bactéries du sol, c'est les animaux que je vous ai montré tout à l'heure, ils savent faire ça.
Par contre ça passera par la polyculture, on fera pas une parcelle où il n'y aura qu'une seule plante produite, ce sera pas que des patates ou que des navets
J'ai un ami tout près de Rennes qui fait ses petits pois sous son blé, c'est magique.
Il gagne beaucoup plus que le type d'à côté qui fait que du blé et il a divisé les pesticides par 30 par 40 par 50 par 100
Mais il fait son petit pois sous son blé, c'est tout.
Et quand il a fini de vendre son blé, il en vend un petit peu moins que le voisin, il a ses petit pois qui
sont en parfait état c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on comprenne ensemble et ça on sait faire
il faut le faire avec le monde agricole pas contre lui bien évidemment
Donc aujourd'hui c'est vrai que le 30 septembre prochain on aura cette grande réunion sur la biodiversité
des nations unies donc on va voir un petit peu ce qu'ils vont sortir.
Donc cette crise de la dégradation de la biodiversité, il faut qu'on la reprenne
et comment travailler aujourd'hui sur la limitation de la propagation de la Covid, on va y venir
Alors ça c'est le rapport du WWF, sorti la semaine dernière, le 15 septembre donc il y à quelques jours, en ce moment il y a pleins de  choses qui
sortent, qui nous dit : "Voilà on a perdu
68%
non pas des espèces disparues mais du nombre d'individus dans les populations vivantes depuis 1970"
On montre ici que partout en fait
au niveau mondial, par continents Amérique, Asie, avec l'Europe nous avons
fait attention en Europ on n'est plus en train de dégrader autant qu'on l'a fait, on a déjà beaucoup dégradé avant ça c'est
clair pendant le moyen âge mais on est en train de réagir plus vite
que des pays, que des régions comme par exemple l'Afrique l'Amérique du Sud
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut encore sauver avec nous, ça c'est super important
Donc voilà le rapport de WWF justement, le corail, regardez les coraux qui est en train de
s'effondrer en ce moment ici les grenouilles partout doucement ça c'est très important aussi bien sur les mammifères et les oiseaux on a perdu
30 % de nos oiseaux.
En quinze dans les terres agricoles, des oiseaux communs l'alouette des champs, le moineau domestique, le vanneau huppé des choses qu'on connaissait bien
et là il ya un problème d'éducation
Moi quand j'étais un petit garçon élevé à la pointe Bretonne
tous mes amis étaient fils de paysan ils connaissait tous les noms des oiseaux de leurs champs
Aujourd'hui le jeune paysan il connaît même pas le nom de ses oiseaux, il connait pas le nom de ses papillons
Comment voulez vous, si on recréer pas  ce lien entre le monde agricole
et la de diversité qui l'entoure
ça ne marchera pas le respect, l'observation
Moi je vois beaucoup de paysans avec nous qui travaillent maintenant sur
l'essence participative, ils nous donne, nous alimente en données, c'est magique comme un médecin peut le faire, comme un vétérinaire peut le faire, un marin pêcheur,
un ostréiculteur
c'est vraiment tellement.. Ils sont sur le terrain tout le temps, ce que nous on ne peut pas faire ils sont partout et tout le temps
donc plus ces gens-là arriveront à se fédérer pour amener la donnée au système
Puis on me dit "voilà moi j'ai ramassé mon premier pruneaux à Agen
tel jour à telle heure" et on voit très bien le changement climatique
Les vendanges à Banyuls quand je suis parti là-bas ça fait maintenant vingt ans commençait le 10 septembre
cette année les blancs étaient finis le 15 août
vingt ans
c'est pareil en Crozes-hermitage, c'est pareil en Margaux, c'est pareil dans tous les crus. Donc c'est vrai que
il se passe des choses qui, encore une fois.. C'est pas que ça change qui me gêne c'est l'accélération du changement en fait
Vous l'aurez faisant le rapport du WWF, aujourd'hui on cultive en fait on mange 6000 espèces de plantes différentes
mais neuf font les deux tiers de la production mondiale
donc c'est vrai que l'on mange 40 espèces d'animaux, huit font 95 % on mange tous la même chose on mange
souvent du cochon
de la vache
du poulet on mange tous la même chose d'un peu de moutons de temps en temps le cheval de moins en moins ici en bretagne
et ailleurs c'est vrai
et puis voilà quelquefois du canard oui dans le sud ouest on mange beaucoup donc on mange tous 5,6 animaux
alors qu'il y en a 1,3 millions de différents donc c'est vrai que ça relance tous les débats là dessus
est-ce qu'on va pas éhontément les favorisés pour ne plus laisser de place pour le reste c'est la vraie question
Donc ce déclin de la nature a été calculéeà 480 milliards de dollars par an donc dix mille milliards de dollars d'ici
2050 donc ça veut dire que ça peut se résumer aussi en systèmes sonnants et trébuchants
donc impératif de changer
agir
Et là dessus débarque la Covid. C'est un virus de chauve souris voilà, c'est elle, elle s'appelle rhinolophus affinis
On l'a connait bien, ça fait 20 ans qu'on y travaille avec les collègues des museums
On va dans les grottes en Chine depuis longtemps, on sait que c'est dangereux
Aujourd'hui il y a pratiquement 400 virus dans les chauves-souris qui peuvent sortir quand on veut, foutons leur la paix
Laissons ces chauves-souris là où elles sont arrêtons d'aller les chercher dans leur grotte, de les garder vivante sur un marché dans des conditions ignobles
Elle fait caca sur une bestiole qui est en dessous, un pangolin, une civette masqué
Et puis ben, il mute, il mute ce virus et se met à attaquer les cellules humaines, ce  qu'il ne savait pas faire avant
ça devait pas se passer, ça s'est passé parce qu'on a été ignoble
Dans le traitement du vivant et de la biodiversité on a mélangé animaux domestiques animaux sauvages il faut surtout pas faire ça
Alors on me dit : "Dans ce cas c'est facile monsieur le professeur, vous savez ce qu'on fait, on tue toutes les chauves-souris de la Terre" ben voyons..
Bah non parce que le fait qu'elles existent
limite ces virus
Le virus une fois qu'il a réussi réussi à quitter la chauve-souris et à passer à l'humain il n'a pas envie de revenir à chauves-souris
c'est elle qui limite le système quand il y a une grande biodiversité, on appelle ça l'effet de dilution
dans une grotte ou ailleurs ou dans une forêt tropicale
le virus sans arrêt il va rencontrer des individus qui sont résistants
parce qu'ils sont tous différents les uns par rapport aux autres et c'est un parcours du combattant
il passe pas il passe pas si jamais demain on diminue le nombre d'espèces vivantes
et on diminue le nombre d'espèces qui sont sensibles à ce virus
il a un boulevard devant lui il a passé des barrières il a envahi tout
gardons-les avec nous ce sont les meilleurs alliés pour empêcher ces passages
de pathogènes
de l'animal à l'humain et l'humain s'est toujours contaminé comme ça toute façon toutes les maladies depuis 50 milles ans viennent d'espèces différentes très peu des
singes très très peu mais beaucoup du cochon, du chien, du chat de la vache bien sûr ou d'animaux sauvages
ça passe vous rappelez l'épidémie de MERS dans les pays Arabes du golfe il y a
dis ans.. C'était les dromadaires
Chauves-souris dromadaires le Nipah c'était le cochon
Au Mexique a une grosse épidémie c'est le cochon si la grippe espagnole c'était le canard
donc dès le moment où on commence à mal élevés ces bestioles et bien le virus ou la bactérie elle passe de l'animal sauvage au domestique
domestique à l'humain
Là on pense qu'il est passé peut être par le pangolin, dissémination effarante, ce sont les avions qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure effectivement
Pas de vaccin pour l'instant quand j'entends des gens qui me dise "Oui c'est l'Institut Pasteur qui a inventé le virus" Arretez
Moi je leur dit aux types :  "Pourquoi l'Institut Pasteur va inventer un virus dangereux" "Bah tu comprends il veut vendre des vaccins"
Ah je dis "Ecoute, si je veux vendre des vaccins il est prêt dans mon congélateur à côté."
Je vais pas le préparer pendant trois ans pour que je le fasse, il sera plus efficace il aura muter le virus
Ca n'a pas de sens
Même quand Montagnier il dit des conneries, il dit qu'il y a des traces de hiv dans le Covid, c'est débile
En fait bien sûr qu'on retrouve les séquences un peu analogue parce qu'un virus est ultra petit
C'est la petitesse total plus petit que ça on ne  peut pas exister
Donc il y à des séquences qui ressemblent mais pas du tout plus proche du hiv que n'importe quel autre virus en fait
donc simplement suffit.. Alors une vraie question c'est est-ce qu'il a été bricolé ou pas nous on a
aucun signe, je vais y revenir tout de suite, pour l'instant
Je sais pas ce qu'il s'est passé. Donc il est infectieux on a dit qu'ils tuaient les gens de surcharge pondérale
une longue liste de virus, je viens de vous parler de l'effet de dilution et six autres tout à l'heure
voilà le coronavirus ici là il est relâché par des cellules pulmonaires donc qu'il avait contaminé
Donc le pangolin ça reste une hypothèse peut-être le pangolin
Ca c'est la Chinoise qui raconte en ce moment, mais comme elle est très proche de Trump j'hésite à la croire, mais elle dit que "j'ai la preuve
que c'est le labo de Wuhan qui a inventé le virus."
Vous avez vu sur les réseaux sociaux hier on n'a rien pour l'instant, nous l'a bien regarder les séquences pour l'instant en scientifiques
spécialistes des génomes des virus, c'est pas mon cas mais j'ai des collègues au jardin des plantes qui font ça, ils me disent on a absolument
aucune raison de penser qu'ils auraient été bricolé et manipulé
donc ça peut très bien être effectivement être une chauve souris, un pangolin, une civette masquée ou autre chose
Et puis il est devenu infectieux chez l'humain.
Donc on a regardé des séquences un peu partout
Donc 380 virus et les chauves-souris voyez un petit peu donc c'est vrai que l'agriculture intensive l'urbanisation massive
tout ça doit nous faire réinterpréter ces questions de
prédisposition de l'espèce sauvage vers les domestiques et de mélange de tout ça et ça c'est vraiment très important d'y venir
Voilà, alors sur la mortalité, faut pas exagérer non plus quand on vous parle de seconde vague ça c'est de ce matin le chiffre
Ben regardez, écoute ça c'est la France, l'Europe est là, donc on a eu le pic terrible du moins là, il mourrait en France 1500
personnes par jour je crois que c'est le 23 avril le pic qu'on a eu en France là on est on est à deux quoi
donc alors il y a une peut-être.. Ce n'est pas une deuxième vague en plus on me parle de deuxième vague
Y a pas eu une première vague ici de toute façon donc s'il y à une vague c'est la première ici vous voyez que
arrêtons de coller la trouille à tout le monde
il faut vraiment se poser des questions il faut faire attention pour nos anciens ça c'est absolument très clair mais mettre des masques à des
enfants moi je suis content ça sert absolument à rien on les terrorise pour rien du tout
Quand vous êtes sur une plage quand vous êtes dans la rue que le premier humain à 30 mètres ça sert à rien ne mettez
pas de masque, faites du vélo sans masque, sautez, riez
lancez ce que vous voulez, roulez vous par terre on se contamine dans la même pièce avec la même
climatisation avec la même machine à café ça oui
Dans le tgv, c'est pour ça que j'ai beaucoup hésité à venir
Certainement on avait vérifié des traces de virus dans le tgv y en avait plein à Brest quand on emmenait les parisiens malades là à Brest
au mois d'avril dernier mais bon donc ça veut dire qu'effectivement
c'est à prendre au sérieux je suis pas en train de dire que c'est pas quelque chose qui est important
simplement n'exagérons pas non plus la réaction je pense qu'il faut garder la tête froide
il faut être conscient que cette chose là est très dangereuse pour des personnes qui sont fragilisées
on a dit tout à l'heure des gens qui sont obèses qui sont diabète de type 2 qui ont eu des cancers qui ont été
des fumeurs c'est très clair et puis ben
on fait attention à eux
mais de là à mettre comme on l'a fait là des gens dans des ehpad alors empêché de voir leur famille
il y aura plus de morts à cause de ces comportements là que simplement la question de nous protéger vis-à-vis du virus
Ah une boîte de nuit ce n'est pas recommandé ça je suis d'accord. Allez vous cracher dessus dans les boîtes de nuit bah
c'est le meilleur truc, les clusters c'est là qu'ils passent, des mariages, ils passent dans des fêtes de famille
quand ici en Bretagne on a crié après les parisiens on s'est rendu compte qu'il y a eu beaucoup plus de
clusters dans des familles qui se réunissait que dans ces bandits de parisiens touristes qui venaient passer lors
lors leur confinement à la pointe bretonne à l'île de Ré il y à eu une manif
On revient à ce qu'est l'espèce humaine, ça veut dire que bah oui sur la faute de l'autre
donc faire attention oui mais n'exagérons pas non plus la situation
Voilà ça c'est donc les morbidités que je vous montrais, ça en fait par semaine
donc voilà ce que tue le coronavirus entre 81 et 86 ans,  81 ans c'est la moyenne entre la France et l'Italie
C'est de ce matin ces chiffres là aussi c'est tout neuf
dont 115 milles décès en excès ça c'est l'INED, donc vous savez ce qu'ils font ils mesurent les morts en France depuis tout le temps
et dont on regarde sur une épidémie la différence il y a ceux qui ont été comptés
dans les hôpitaux et dans les ehpad c'est pas toujours très précis mais simplement on tient compte de toute la mortalité en france
ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a surestimé les morts du Covid dans les hôpitaux français
tous les gens qui sont morts à l'hôpital aux mois de mars avril mai, Covid
non et deuxièmement ce qui est important aussi c'est qu'il y a eu plein de gens qui sont morts pas ce qu'ils n'ont pas été traités
le confinement à boire et à manger et je dis pas qu'il fallait pas confiner du tout, c'est pas ce que je dis, il aurait fallu commencer bien avant
on l'a commencé beaucoup trop tard il fallait arrêter les avions chinois bien avant il fallait les arrêter au début du mois de mars
pas comme on a fait.
100 jours on a mit
pour arrêter les avions chinois donc c'est là que
Faut regarder ce qui se passe et puis surtout faites du sport  ! Moins vous ferez de sport plus vous serez contaminable, alors faites du sport
Donc 115 milles décès, voyez qu'on était à 90 milles en 2018
140 milles..
Bon oui il y aura une surmortalité, ça va faire baisser un tout petit peu la durée de vie des français
Un tout petit peu mais pas beaucoup à ce que dit l'INED aujourd'hui on va attendre un peu on est encore un petit peu tôt pour
voir jusqu'où ça va aller je lis pas dans la boule de cristal mais je ne crois pas une énorme reprise aujourd'hui
de l'épidémie il faut que les gens se contaminent le drame qui m'embête le plus dans aujourd'hui la communication du gouvernement
c'est qu'en fait on est passé des morts
ça c'est indiscutable, des morts, alors par contre je vous dis on a compté des gens qui n'étaient pas mort du Covid comme mort du Covid bon
C'est comme ça on surestime le problème mais surtout on est passé à des tests qui sont très peu fiable
ils sont même pas fiable à la moitié en fait ces tests ils pouvaient avoir un test positif négatif vous savez pas trop vous en êtes
et puis plus vous en testez plus vous en trouvez, bien évidemment c'est mathématique !
on faisait pas de test au mois d'avril donc effectivement on trouvait pas maintenant on fait que ça on en trouve
puis à côté et on dit aux gens "Aller lancez vous vers une contamination générale pour avoir une immuno défense"
collective. Puis on dit "faut pas l'attraper".
Les messages sont dramatiques, je ne sais pas comment, en fait, on peut communiquer bien avec les gens. Les masques en mars ne servait à rien parce
qu'on n'en avait pas
maintenant on en met à tout le monde dans des endroits où on n'en a pas besoin
C'est là vraiment qu'il y a vraiment tous ensemble, collectivement une réaction a avoir de je dirais d'intelligence
mais qu'on arrête de nous prendre pour des enfants les Allemands ont réagi très différent des Français il y avait un bel article sur
Merkel et Macron, il y a quelques temps on disait en fait on a infantilisé les français
Moi je suis admiratif de la façon dont on a réagi on a tous accepter ça
le coût social est monstrueux, le coût économique est monstrueux. Qui va payer la dette ? Ce sont nos enfants encore à cette histoire là.
Encore une je dis pas qu'il fallait pas le faire c'est facile après de dire ça mais
Comment on pouvait le faire surtout. Et puis il faut qu'on arrête, on ne peut pas gouverner un pays par la peur ça j'y crois absolument
pas il faut que les gens soit responsables face à quelque chose
Quand on.. Je me rappelle un vieux monsieur qui disait, quand Macron avait dit "Nous sommes en guerre"
Le vieux monsieur a dit "Vous savez
nous quand on partait à la guerre il y avait quand même beaucoup moins
que 0 1% en fait qu'ils revenaient pas beaucoup plus que 0 1% qui revenait pas" on va évidemment ça c'est clair
la guerre c'est pas ça
J'ai écrit un papier en fait notre ennemi n'est pas le virus c'est nos comportements à nous en fait qui sont le problème
Voilà
Donc le climat, j'en avais parlé un petit peu, on va terminer là dessus donc le climat c'est effectivement quelque chose
qui est que bah c'est parti c'est trop tard pour l'empêcher de changer
qu'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui, la mer monte la température change c'est un vrai problème
ça c'est ce qu'on peut faire, entre autre avec les viticulteurs avec les
les éleveurs comment est-ce que le climat va changer qu'est ce qui va se passer ou est-ce qu'il va pleuvoir pas pleuvoir
quels sont des températures qu'on aura dans 10 ans, dans 20 ans
et c'est très important on a un travail très avancé dans la région Nouvelle Aquitaine
J'encourage vraiment les bretons à faire pareil vous avez les cerveaux pour faire ça mais ça demande un petit peu de moyens
comment le niveau de la mer va augmenter ici en Bretagne ? Et puis surtout regardez aussi les précipitations dans les 50 années qui viennent
Voilà donc on laisse faire, c'est quatre degrés
On fait un gros effort, ça peut-être deux
Donc l'avenir est entre nos mains ça ça demande beaucoup plus d'efforts que l'histoire de la Covid alors j'espère que la Covid
ce qu'on a vécu là
va nous inciter à essayer de changer un petit peu à faire pression sur les systèmes pour qu'on change un peu
c'est très difficile, parce que pour éviter plus de 2 degrés ça veut dire laisser là où ils sont
80% des gisements actuellement connus de charbon et de pétrole vous rendez compte c'est.
C'est considérable et les jeunes disent qu'ils ne veulent pas de pétrole on n'en veut plus c'est même pas la peine ils disent, plus de matière
plastique
c'est jouable mais faut vraiment on a vraiment à changer très fort
Voilà donc je termine sur les maladies on en a parlé un petit peu tout à l'heure qui sont liées à ces émergences
sur les maladies qui sont liées à l'âge, on a des maladies qu'on n'avait pas parce qu'on ne vivait pas aussi vieux
l'exposition au soleil tout ça c'est lié effectivement au changement climatique ou aux changements de la biodiversité
sachant que le gros problème la maladie la plus grave c'est la pauvreté
Regardez aux Etats Unis où ils ont le droit eux de mettre la couleur de la peau des morts, c'est interdit en France mais ils
ont quatre fois plus de morts chez les populations noires
Pas parce qu'ils sont plus réceptifs mais parce qu'ils sont pauvres, ils sont obèses et très pauvre
Donc ça c'est vrai que encore une fois
je reviens à ce que je disais tout à l'heure, arrêtons un système où on se croit social
où on admet que parce qu'on est pauvre on mange que des saletés
c'est plus possible
Durée de vie en France, tout à l'heure je vous ai dit, c'est 84 ans chez les femmes 80 chez les garçons
Vous savez qu'elle est la durée de vie d'un clochard à Paris
Imaginez la vie d'une femme clocharde à Paris, vous en voyez tous les jours
La terreur du viol en permanence elle est battue, maltraitée, elle ne mange pas à sa faim
Ce qui veut dire que si vous ne chauffez pas quelqu'un l'hiver si vous ne le refroidissez pas l'été
s'il est sans arrêt en carence alimentaire
et dans la stress permanent de l'agression vous vivez 46 ans
On côtoie ça absolument tous les jours, donc c'est vrai qu'on a vraiment un effort chacun pour essayer de voir comment est-ce qu'on peut
améliorer.. Là je parle de chez nous mais pensez à des populations
Le pays où on vie le moins longtemps c'est le Zimbabwe, c'est 46 ans la moyenne au Zimbabwe
vous voyez que c'est pas simple
Je termine sur le long terme, on fait quoi ? Le climat, l'eau, les déchets
Alors moi j'ai au moins deux aspects très importants
ce que j'appelle moi l'essence participative vous participez tout à ça
C'est à dire aider nos scientifiques à archiver la donnée, à la divulguer, à la mettre en forme, à la synthétiser
et ça c'est dix mille personnes dont beaucoup de gens en Bretagne
charcutier dentiste plombier pêcheurs paysans, il n'y a aucune hiérarchie dans ce que je dis là je prends n'importe qui, qui nous raconte des histoires voilà
"J'ai mangé ma première polos, ma prunelle", "j'ai mangé ma fraise dans mon jardin", " j'ai vu tel papillon"
C'est génial ! Vingt mille personnes nous appellent tous les jours à Paris au muséum
Nous on est 2500 donc on avance comme ça, on archive ça, c'est des banques de données gigantesques et on lit le changement climatique
Et là il montrait qu'en 18 ans nos oiseaux ont fait 33 km vers le nord, nos papillons 114
et que pour un degré de plus en Bretagne,
ils devront faire 250 km vers le nord donc tous les oiseaux qu'on a ici ils seront rendus en Grande Bretagne
Donc c'est intéressant on fera des réserves ici pour protéger une espèce et elle ne sera plus là dans 20 ans, elle sera partie
En échange on aura des espèces du Maroc qui seront arrivées chez nous bien sûr, chacun se balade
Vers le nord dans l'hémisphère nord. Vers le sud dans l'hémisphère sud
Et puis la bio-inspiration, ça c'est un de mes dadas
Tout à l'heure Maëtte parlait du CEEBIOS, c'est un groupe qui a été lancé il y a maintenant dix ans
Et qui en fait regroupe 400 entreprises dont les très gros,  l'Oréal, Saint-Gobain et
Renault en fait le but c'est de changer nos matériaux pour faire des voitures, des vélos tout ce que vous voulez, des maisons
Changer les couleurs, les formes pour qu'elle soit beaucoup plus durable la bio-inspiration c'est faire mieux qu'aujourd'hui
Plus efficace
plus durable qui n'émet aucune substance toxique avec beaucoup moins d'énergie
et moins cher. On peut rêver avec ça et bien la nature sait faire ça
l'agroécologie c'est ça on arrivera à produire plus sur les mêmes surfaces grâce à l'agroécologie
et pour ça il faut faire appel aux vivants et puis il faut travailler avec en permanence
Donc là vous avez ce petit coléoptère qui sait faire de l'eau en plein désert elle, cette éponge là elle sait faire du béton armé
excellent qui marche très bien
là vous avez le CX (aérodynamisme) le plus beau du monde avec la tête du martin pêcheur mais il faisait beaucoup de bruit ce train
donc on l'a recouvert d'un système qui ressemble aux plumes du hibou il va vite il fait pas de bruit, c'est génial
Voilà je vous avais parlé de la libellule aussi, elle vole à 90 km avec 2 watts
Elle voit à 360° moi je vois pas ce qui est derrière, elle elle voit derrière
300 images à la seconde, on en a 25
9 techniques de vol, des capteurs de vol qui font rêver tous les pilotes vous imaginez, elles savent faire ça
Elles encaisse 30 g en accélération 30 fois l'accélération de la terre
Nous on va à la foire de rennes tout à l'heure là, je vous met dans le manège où vous payez 10 euros
le plus terrible hein, on vous centrifuge à 5g vous vomissez votre quatre heure
et vous avez payé 10 euros. 30g ma libellule ! Comment elle fait diantre
Alors au lieu de mettre des saletés dans leur mare et au lieu de faire des parkings par-dessus allons voir comment elles font
Je suis aller faire une conférence à la marine nationale sur un beau navire de guerre sur le Tonnerre
Qui est le successeur de la Jeanne d'Arc, le porte-hélicoptères Français devant tous les types de Brest je leur dit : "voilà où il faut chercher vos inspirations
dans le vivant qui fait beaucoup mieux que nous."
Il m'a quand même dit le pacha il m'a dit "Oh Gilles tu as raison j'aime bien ce que tu fais mais
j'ai du mal à mettre quand même quatre
types de l'infanterie de marine sur ta libellule" mais ouais mais bon..
Voilà, je fini sur ce que l'humain a gagné en 140 ans
par rapport à vos anciens, on mangeait deux fois moins
on mesurait 15 centimètres de moins.
On voit ça dans les cimetières
On vivait 35 ans de moins on faisait 30 kg de moins y compris l'obésité
On a multiplié par sept les humains et par dix les rendements agricoles c'est ça le progrès
maintenant comment on l'utilise
Edgar Morin nous dit "d'un côté les moteurs du système peuvent être très bénéfiques pour l'humanité très délétères de l'autre" 30 kg de plus
Vous courez moins vite, vous mangez trop
35 ans d'espérance de vie c'est pas une mince performance, grâce aux progrès de la médecine mais ça s'arrête en ce moment ça s'arrête
Là les Chinois, on va cloner des mecs à deux mètres 42
ça c'est la durée de vie des femmes en France, ça c'est les garçons
Voilà donc l'espérance de vie en fait elles n'augmentent pas ça veut dire que est de plus en plus de
femmes chez les femmes c'est pas.. A 110 ans j'ai regardé y a plus aucun homme en France à 110 ans, y a que des femmes
à 100 ans c'est trois quart de femmes
un quart d'hommes. Ce qui veut dire effectivement que y a de plus en plus de centenaires ça c'est très clair
mais par contre l'âge absolu 113 114 115 116 ça n'augmente pas du tout depuis depuis dix ans
Jeanne Calment reste le record imbattable à 122 ans et 164 jours
l'arlésienne - la doyenne actuelle elle à 117 maintenant
Kane Tanaka. Sur les 50 derniers records du monde, 48 femmes. Bon, les femmes vous vivez quand même plus longtemps que les garçons
Donc ici c'est intéressant parce que il y a bien une limite quelque part alors si on accepte nos limites ça changera beaucoup de choses effectivement
Là je vous ai mis des records j'ai pris les meilleures performances de l'année sur le 800 mètres plat les filles les garçons
le saut en hauteur et le lancement du poids. Vous voyez qu'il y a des limites mais là on arrive des choses qui sont assez étrange
Pourquoi aujourd'hui, mesdames, mesdemoiselles, aucune femmes au monde ne lance le poids aussi loin que l'Allemande de l'est en 1986
Là vous avez vu, le tour de France est fini
avant-hier, déjà il y a beaucoup de soupçons qui pèsent sur ce garçon de 22 ans, il a eu 22 ans aujourd'hui
Pogacar
Questions qu'on peut se poser effectivement, quand le type il monte à
443 watts, est-ce qu'un humain est capable non shooté, de monter à
443 watts on l'a calculé, on l'a mesuré. Ca se calcule sur une pente à la vitesse vu sa masse corporelle
Rappelez-vous les épisodes Armstrong ça nous rappelle des mauvais souvenirs
Je n'accuse pas du tout Pogacar d'être dopé, je dis simplement que là c'est clair, pourquoi elles faisaient ça les filles ?
On les shootait toute petite dans le biberon à la méthyl testostérone de garçons
Elles n'ont jamais eu du règles de leur vie, doping organisé
Allemagne de l'est, ça s'est passé également en
Russie y a pas très longtemps et en Chine tous les Chinois qui ont gagné la médaille d'or aux JO de Pékin
sont tombés pour dopage depuis
donc ça relance le débat : est-ce qu'on est prêt à accepter nos limites ? C'est la question qu'on se pose souvent finalement
et Confucius disait "si on accepte nos limites, on est beaucoup mieux, en les comprenant, capable de s'adapter aux conditions qui changent."
Là c'est la durée de vie voyez ici, Jeanne Calment est là
Après on a comparé ça à la consommation énergétique, chez des vieilles personnes on les chauffe donc l'hiver on les refroidi l'été
ils prennent vingt médicaments par jour on a calculé tout ça hein
Et c'est normal ça finit effectivement au niveau énergétique. Ce n'est pas par hasard si on vit vieux
en Italie, en Espagne, en Allemagne, en France, au Japon, aux Etats-Unis, on vit pas à ces âges là
110 ans dans les pays Africains.
Donc on a
c'est intéressant d'y réfléchir parce que les coûts énergétiques sont absolument délirant quand vous regardez les coûts moyens bien sûr
vous arrivez à des pays qui font des dépenses énergétiques qui sont gigantesques
Il y a des modes de vie qui peuvent se prêter aussi à des gens qui vivent plus longtemps ça existe aussi bien sûr
mais là  on tombe à à des âge.. Donc nous pour nous notre idée c'est que
il va bien se passer un moment où
on va plutôt
diminuer l'espérance de vie et c'est le papier de l'INED qui est sorti il y à quelques mois, il montre que depuis 2008 en France on diminue l'espérance de vie
elle va baisser un petit peu aussi cette année avec la Covid, c'est est normal
puisqu'on perd des gens qui étaient justement entre 80 et puis 90, ou 100. ça c'est clair
bon maintenant, on ne va pas à l'infini continuer à grandir et en grandissant c'est pareil les plus grands humains sont les Hollandais
devant les Danois et ça fait dix ans à peu près qu'ils ont arrêté de grandir aussi donc c'est intéressant
Il se passe des choses, alors
L'explications ou bien on a des limites physiologiques c'est possible, pour un physiologiste comme moi oui ou alors on avait encore des marges de manœuvre
mais les autos agressions qu'on créé par notre environnement qui se dégradent font qu'on peut pas aller plus loin en fait
Par exemple moi j'ai une question qui me turlupine beaucoup toutes ces femmes qui vivent qui on 100 ans aujourd'hui, pleins de mamans d'amis
elle me raconte ma maman à 100 ans donc elles sont nées en 1920
1920 une femme enceinte ne mangeait aucun pesticide
Et le bébé non plus. J'attends de voir combien de temps vont vivre les femmes nées après
1952, quand on a commencé en France à mettre des pesticides absolument partout c'est une vraie question mais on verra ça dans quelques temps
Voilà je termine par un peu de philosophie ça je vous l'avais montrer aussi donc c'est ce que Aurobindo disait
"Un changement intérieur de l'humain
transformation radicale de l'humain" ça pour un biologiste ça s'appelle une métamorphose
c'est le mot que Edgar Morin utilise? Ce sera mes dernières images il dit en fait
"Le développement humain, la science, la technique, l'économie et le profit en économie capitaliste
cela permet de créer de l'emploi, mais chacun de ses moteurs peut être
valable ou au contraire dangereux pour l'humanité" il dit en fait l'avenir
on a parlé il est très inquiétant et la Covid de nous révèle aussi quelque chose
et j'aime bien ce qu'il dit "Après il y a toujours eu de l'improbable dans l'histoire de la Terre et de l'humanité"
Faut pas qu'on oublie ça parce que
arrêtons de dire aux jeunes c'est foutu, ce qu'il faut dire aux jeunes c'est que l'improbable, ce qu'on fait ce soir ensemble là
Pour quoi on se bat ce soir là
Pour que le probable qu'on nous promet là ne se produise pas et pour ça il faut qu'on change
Si on change pas c'est impossible dans l'évolution
Toutes les espèces qui se sont adaptées au cours du temps à des changements extérieurs
ont changé, et nous on ne change toujours pas ! On reveut le même nombre d'avions on reveut le même mode de vie
ça c'est pas possible ça
Il parle de métamorphose Edgar d'ailleurs il prend il prend un terme de biologistes il dit "on est homo faber" comme disait tout à l'heure
Michel on est pas mal Demens mais on n'est pas encore Sapiens
Et puis il disait "à force de sacrifier l'essentiel" au président macron "à l'urgence" ce qu'on fait en ce moment
"on finit par oublier l'urgence de l'essentiel en fait"
lisez les tweets d'Edgar Morin. Edgar Morin le 8 juillet 2021
aura un siècle
il est né le 8 juillet
1921, lisez ses tweets du matin
Pas mal.
Les neurones fonctionnent bien, il court un peu moins vite il entend pas très bien mais n'empêche que les neurones marche très très bien
voilà
Avec des gens comme ça puis il me disait aussi récemment "Tu sais un pays comme la France où les grands philosophes ce sont Bernard Henri Lévy
Finkielkraut
et Luc Ferry il est vraiment en décadence."
Revenons à nos Grecs anciens, les maîtres de la philosophie ou aux Chinois qu'on oublie bien souvent aussi bien sûr
Voilà donc la question qu'on me pose c'est la résilience, on me dit bah justement où va être la résilience, simplement on oublie une chose qui est importante pour moi
Quand vous êtes agressé, là c'est le procès de Charlie en ce moment de rentrer sur le Bataclan on a travaillé sur le massacre du
Rwanda, sur l'inceste, qui est une horreur totale, ça existe chez nous ici en Bretagne
et puis sur les écosystèmes comment face à un trauma comme ça
vous vous refaites quelque chose n'oubliez jamais une chose vous pouvez pas résilié si vous êtes mort
or pour l'instant on l'a oublié, ne détruisons pas
on prend les abeilles comme exemple pour le terrestre, les méduses au niveau marin mais ça c'est une dépression nerveuse
donc vous modélisez, vous n'êtes pas mort mais vous revenez plus ou moins près de l'état antérieur ça prend du temps
ça prend de la souffrance et ça prend de l'effort c'est pareil pour les écosystèmes
Voilà je vous laisse lire ça donc qu'est ce qu'on fait
Le confinement, on a développé le télétravail on a digitalisé
on a vu les gaz à effet de serre qui s'était effondré pendant quelques temps c'était spectaculaire
Le président Macron nous dit le jour d'après sera pas comme les jours d'avant j'espère bien
Retour sur soi, sécurité de la famille, maltraitance des femmes et des enfants, c'est très important
Alors deux solutions : où on fait comme avant, ce que demande le monde de l'entreprise vous écoutez les gens de
l'aéronautique on revient comme avant
en vendant des billets 10 billets 10 euros, je suis désolé, si on refait ça on va s'en prendre à un autre virus ça c'est clair
Ou alors on se restructure on change complètement dans une optique de durabilité c'est ça la vraie question
Et ça, ça s'oppose beaucoup aux trames des  grandes multinationales donc c'est un vrai combat. Voilà c'est ma dernière image Maëtte
Le vivant innove constamment et ceci depuis la nuit des temps
une innovation utilisable par tous y compris pour les gilets jaunes et c'est pas ce  qu'on fait dans les industries d'aujourd'hui
Le vivant fait tout avec une très grande
économie d'énergie et le vivant ne fait jamais une substance qui va l'auto empoisonné il produit des poisons extrêmement violent mais il sait les dégrader
Donc voilà c'est ça ma conclusion
Arrêtez cette économie actuelle stupide et suicidaire qui consiste à faire du profit en détruisant ou surexploitant la nature et c'est ça
Et c'est ça qui a amené le coronavirus
voilà,
merci
Merci mon cher Gilles. Merci  beaucoup pour cette belle conférence avec
toujours cette énergie et cet enthousiasme
donc
il faut garder la mesure
retrouver le bon sens
le pire n'est jamais sûr et vive la vie on peut résumer tout ça comme ça
Si  les jeunes n'ont pas envie de l'avenir qu'est ce qui va se passer, on n'arrête pas les dégoûter
quand la réaction la pire d'une jeune fille c'est de me dire je ferai pas d'enfant
c'est pas elle que je critique c'est le système qui l'a amené à dire ça et je la comprends en plus, donc c'est vrai qu'on
a une responsabilité
gigantesque donc c'est pas le fait.. On peut pas continuer comme ça
alors on aura peu de temps pour des questions parce que gilles a beaucoup beaucoup
débordé mais toujours..
Il fallait m'arrêter, faut me le dire, me faire signe
Non parce que c'est passionnant on avait envie d'entendre la suite et c'est difficile
Voilà oui on pourrait passer encore beaucoup plus de temps donc on va prendre quelques questions dans la salle et quelques questions
sur
sur internet
Est ce que quelqu'un a une question est ce que vous voulez poser une question dans la salle
André peut-être après parce qu'on va laisser un petit peu la place aux autres hein.
Qui est-ce qui veut poser une question dans la salle
est ce que oui là-haut
tout là-haut et puis ici monsieur  alors monsieur vous ça vous ennuie pas de vous lever et puis
juste enlever le masque le temps de poser la question on dira rien
Y a t-il une pertinence des théories de Darwin ?
Oui
bien sûr
Monsieur de monde si aujourd'hui dans ce qui se passe c'est ce qu'on a une pertinence des théories de Darwin oui on
l'a vu tout à l'heure pour mesurer l'évolution du plancton
en fait
le problème c'est qu'on a fait dire à Darwin des choses complètement.. qui n'a jamais dites, le darwinisme social
l'entreprise doit manger celle d'un côté, il n'a jamais dit ça en fait il a fait un travail sur la sélection naturelle en disant qu'
à l'instant t il faut les bons gènes face à une situation qu'on n'a encore jamais vécu et de la chance
je crois que c'est un petit peu tout ça finalement qui se passe
Et souvent ce qui est intéressant c'est que les gens croient que c'est le plus gros le plus fort qui transmet ses gènes c'est pas
vrai du tout du tout du tout hein. C'est le plus malin souvent qui les transmets ces gènes.
Alors c'est vrai que maintenant on a un brassage de population tout à fait différent le cerveau humain a grandi pendant quelques
millions d'années puis bon maintenant il grandit pas on n'a pas un cerveau plus gros et pendant longtemps parce qu'en fait
n'avait accès aux femmes que des hommes qui effectivement était utile pour la tribu
et surtout c'était la domestication du feu qui a permis ça parce qu'on se raconte des histoires le soir au coin du feu
et là on voit très bien la libération de la main, ça c'est Bergson, puis surtout le fait qu'on se raconte ce qui s'est passé
et ça, ça a socialiser énormément l'humain ça c'est absolument évident
Mais c'est vrai que oui bien sûr tout
Gould disait en fait, c'est le Darwin du 20e, il disait en fait l'évolution c'est des longues périodes du temps où il se passe pas grand chose
parce que ça change pas à l'extérieur
les époques précises quand tout change qui oblige le vivant à faire des espèces et à spécier beaucoup plus vite
Alors je crois qu'il y avait une question dans le fond vous vous mettez debout vous parler fort fort fort
Enlevez le masque le temps que vous êtes debout vous êtes assez loin là
Merci beaucoup, j'avais juste une question
Tel que je le comprends
la science, les scientifiques, pendant les trois quatre derniers siècles ont été avec le progrès ont été avec l'économie ont été un moteur
Et là 10, 20, 30 ans j'ai l'impression que la science de plus en plus tire la sonnette d'alarme écologique,
environnementale et climatique dans tous les sens les scientifiques qui voit en premier, entre guillemets
les choses se passer et qui les prévoit
quelque part vont moins dans le sens du monde économique
et financier
et du progrès entre guillemets
et du coup il ya une divergence là et est-ce qu'ils sont écoutés autant, parce que j'ai l'impression tout le monde tire la sonnette d'alerme avec
36 arguments, très argumentés, très diversifiés, prouvés et sur-prouvés
Et que en face d'un gourou qui va bien, dont vous faisiez l'évocation tout à l'heure..
Il faut poser des questions parce que là comme on entend.. La captation risque..
La réponse est complexe parce que je pense que la science moderne est au service aussi des gouvernements
Il faut résumer quand même un tout petit peu la question..
Le scientifique n'a plus l'indépendance qu'il avait une époque, je crois, parce que c'est les financements des programmes qui vont jouer
donc le vrai scientifique qui est complètement indépendant.. Compliqué.
Donc c'est vrai que la science est là pour donner
que les fake news d'abord a raconter. Parce que les tas de conneries qu'on raconte, il faut les il faut les descendre
mais on a vu les scientifiques ont pas eu un rôle très reluisant durant la covid
et parce qu'ils s'y opposaient des écoles des manières de penser.
Déjà pour moi un conseiller scientifique comme celui là fait que de médecins, ça va pas
Il fallait des médecins évidemment mais..
Des vétérinaires tu m'as dit, il n'y a pas de vétérinaire.
Ces chauve-souris il n'y avait pas de vétérinaires y avait pas d'écologues.
Donc je pense qu'effectivement, il aurait fallu un conseil beaucoup plus pluraliste que ça pour prendre des bonnes décisions
mais la vraie question que vous posez là c'est l'indépendance de la science vis-à-vis des systèmes de financement
Il faudrait bien que ce soit comme vous dites me suis pas convaincu
qu'on soit vraiment indépendant, difficile.
oui ce que monsieur disait c'était que, si j'ai bien compris, c'est d'une certaine façon
la science accompagnait le progrès tout ça marchait un petit peu de pair et puis que maintenant ça
s'éloigne un petit peu les uns des autres et que la science tire le
signal d'alarme et le
et le monde économique ne veut pas ou ne peut pas l'entendre je ne sais pas
Ce monde économique il avance par la technologie inventée par des scientifiques et des ingénieurs donc c'est compliqué
mais c'est une question qui est essentielle, je pense qu'il faut y revenir dessus quel est le rôle d'un scientifique
indépendant public aujourd'hui en gros deux chiffres en france on est soixante mille chercheurs publics et il y en à 200 milles dans les entreprises
donc ça vous fait qu'un petit peu l'état des choses c'est pire aux états unis
C'est une question que se pose beaucoup Etienne Klein que tu connais bien et qui viendra ici au mois de novembre et qui aussi j'ai donné carte blanche pour justement
pouvoir voir comment les choses vont évoluer et pouvoir intervenir sur, sur ce sujet sur la place des scientifiques dans dans notre société
André, vous vouliez poser une question André
Pour éduquer la jeunesse
comment votre discours, votre conférence pourrait être enseigné dans les écoles et collèges
à tout niveau, adapté..
Dès tout petit il faut dire à un petit a quatre ans qu'il est plein de bactéries quoi
il sera heureux comme tout et du coup il fera attention beaucoup plus mais vous avez raison
on commence beaucoup, trop tard vous rendez compte qu'en ce moment on est en train de tuer les sciences de la vie de la terre
je le disais c'est pas possible quoi, nous on comprend pas avec Valérie Masson-Delmotte ça nous rend furieux quoi
Parce que qu'est-ce qu'il fait un bon enseignant, sur votre question, il donne des connaissances ça c'est bien
mais il faut une chose aussi importante
il donne aux gamins un esprit critique
sur ce qu'ils écoutent le gamin et ça on ne le fait pas
parce qu'ils n'ont pas le temps de le faire et ça c'est vous avez raison il faut commencer tout tout tout tout petit et continuer
à LIX (Laboratoire d'informatique de l'École polytechnique) et à l'école nationale d'administration
Les questions vont un peu dans ce sens l'opinion publique semble ne pas prendre la mesure de la catastrophe vers laquelle on se dirige
malgré les alertes est-ce qu'on se débrouille mal pour communiquer autour de ces problèmes bon je pense qu'on peut dire..
Non, je pense que maintenant tout le monde l'admet D'ailleurs moi je rencontre personne qui me dit tout ce que tu dis là il ya
dix ans on m'aurait dit "ouai le climat.."
Non la question c'est que.. On revient à ce que disait Jancovici ça veut dire c'est la fin du mois c'est la fin du monde
Dans l'immédiat de tous les jours est-ce que je vais pas tenir compte de mes immédiatetés
des gens qui se demandent qu'est ce que donner à manger à mes enfants demain
comment ça va se passer est ce que je vais perdre mon travail
et puis du coup on remet un peu plus loin ces questions essentielles mais
mais globalement je pense que ça y est c'est dans le tuyau plus d'un français sur 2 comprend que c'est qu'ils sont là sont importantes
et attend du monde politique qu'il s'en empare
mais par contre on réussira pas ça sans l'entreprise je pense qu'il faut aussi massivement impliquer les entreprises les chefs d'entreprise dans ces questions là
Un monsieur qui suit nos conférences sur internet avec beaucoup de..
je vais y arriver aide-moi
bon d'opiniâtreté
d'opiniâtreté et donc il pose cette question il dit "étant donné qu'on est fait à moitié de bactéries
peut-on dire que trop d'hygiène tue l'hygiène".
Oui !
Oui d'ailleurs on le voit merveilleusement dans les maladies nosocomiales d'hôpital
vous avez des chambres d'hôpitaux tout neuf, je me rappelle c'était à Pompidou à paris
si il reste un être vivant, ce que jamais la nature n'a fait nulle part hein
très banal un pseudomonas, un aeromonas ou bien un staphylocoque, il est immortel il résistera à tout
Et là j'avais un vieux copain chirurgien qui avait trouvé la parade
pour ça répond vraiment là qu'ils ont ce monsieur il conseille comme ça j'ouvre la fenêtre et ça marche
La sepsie poussé à l'extrême c'est pas très bon vous vous lavez pas tous les jours une douche ça c'est clair
Difficile de faire entendre ça aux jeunes qui sont habitués à en une par jour
Il y à de tout, il y en à qui sont cradocs
j'ai vu l'autre jour encore que Henri IV
se lavait que quand il peut être tellement que pour lui-même c'était insupportable
Alors il faut trouver un compromis entre les deux quand même finalement
Maintenant on porte des masques on sera peut-être moins gênés
Prenons la chauve souris par exemple
par quels mécanismes biologiques n'est-elle pas atteinte par tous ces virus qu'elle côtoie
contrairement aux hommes par exemple
Alors là on écrit des bêtises et cette dame a raison, elle est aussi malade. On connaît des cas de grottes
entièrement détruite par un virus mais le virus passe pas la grotte d'à côté
Il effondre une population donc elle aussi, ce qui est intéressant c'est les quelques individus
qui résistent et qui transmettent des gènes de résistance qui vont nous servir après mais elles sont aussi malades
ce serait faux de dire qu'elles ne sont jamais malades
Est-ce que l'agriculture à un avenir avec le changement climatique est est ce que Jean Marc Jancovici
avez vous des projets de travail avec jean marc
oui bien sûr on se connait bien, bien sûr et dans le groupement de..
bon
Bon lui très pro nucléaire d'un côté Jean Marc donc parce ce qu'il dit que pour l'instant
effectivement il n'y a pas de gaz à effet de serre donc il faut qu'on règle les questions des déchets, moi je suis pas un
anti nucléaire notoire non plus mais bon on regarde un petit peu, je pense que demain l'avenir sera beaucoup plus hydrogène
parce que ça coûte très très cher le nucléaire
Monsieur allez-y je vous en prie, il y à quelqu'un là aussi oui alors on revient vers vous après alors allez-y
La semaine dernière à côté de la pointe du Raz avec mon frère,
J'ai vu un spectacle exceptionnel, une chasse de 50 thons rouge à 20 mètres du bord à la pêche du bord
est ce que c'est un spectacle qu'on va avoir souvent
ou alors c'est quelque chose du au réchauffement climatique à la surpêche qui se rapproche de plus en plus
alors je ne sais pas si tout le monde a entendu donc je reprends du thon rouge à la pointe du raz
Le thon rouge elle a failli, non pas disparaître comme les écolos c'est pareil c'est pas que l'extrême,
les stocks français de thon rouge ont été très menacé
entre 2003 et 2007, on flingue tout
le thon il passe, au Guilvinec et puis à Banyuls, de trois euros le kg en 2000 à 100 euros le kilo en 2007
il s'ouvre en france à l'époque à restaurant sushi sashimi par jour
Donc il y à une  demande gigantesque et là
on les détruit mais je connais mieux la méditerranée donc ça veut dire.. Il n'y en avait pas à la pointe du Raz à l'époque
ils sont aux baléares
on les voit en sicile et puis après on les retrouve en libye la guerre de libye éclater ça limite un peu les ébats des
des pêcheurs de thon. En tous cas il est revenu parce qu'on a pris des mesures
on a évité au thon rouge ce qui s'est passé avec la morue à terre-neuve
Sur l'histoire de la présence de thon à la pointe bretonne oui oui la mer se réchauffe
par exemple vous savez ce que j'ai trouvé l'autre jour sur un étal de poissonniers vivant à bordeaux des dorades coryphènes le maï maï
qu'on connaît bien aux Antilles ceux qui ont voyagé un petit peu ou bien à Tahiti
jamais vu dans le golfe de Gascogne quoi, la pêcher là, les anchois de Méditerranée sont rendus effectivement en Bretagne
On pêche de plus en plus de baliste ici et de daurade
on pêche des sars aussi donc oui oui il y a vraiment une migration vers le nord de ces poissons ouai
alors il y a des questions là haut monsieur levez-vous et parlez fort
Bonjour, le GIEC (Groupe d'experts intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du climat) nous alerte bien sûr sur l'augmentation et l'intensification des canicules
des prochaines décennies et nous alerte aussi sur l'insécurité alimentaire
Qu'en pensez-vous ?
Une petite information samedi à Rennes, au mail Mitterrand aura lieu
fête des possible qui rassemble les acteurs qui œuvrent pour la transition écologique
Au mail François Mitterrand de 14h à 18h
D'accord on a retenu
Non, le GIEC enfin tient compte du vivant parce que au départ c'était quand même un petit peu une science de l'ingénieur
on étudiait un volcan pour le volcan sans se préoccuper de ses éruptions..
Températures pareilles qu'est-ce qu'on s'en fiche franchement que le climat chance il n'a pas la vie sur la terre
et l'activité économique maintenant de plus en plus dans les rapports du GIEC
il ya des documents sur la biodiversité et puis sur l'alimentation tout à fait ce que ça aura un impact direct qu'on oublie une chose
c'est important dans votre question
c'est que le climat qui change affectent le vivant
mais on oublie que le vivant qui s'en va a fait aussi le climat en retour la déforestation par exemple
ou la surpêche donc ça joue dans tous les sens mais c'est important d'avoir comme
je dirais un travail final d'aborder ces questions sur l'humanité et l'alimentation
allez si je vous en prie
Bonsoir, je me souviens d'une conférence de vous il y à cinq ans vous aviez très clairement dit que vous ne croyez plus aux politiques
Oui, c'est vrai toujours
Je pense qu'on a tous le même avis là-dessus
ça m'a interpellé quand vous avez parlé des collaborations
avec les entreprises pour la bio-inspiration, c'est aussi les grandes entreprises ?
Oui !
Comment on peut être sûr qu'on peut encore croire en ces gens là ?
Si vous voulez, je dois dire qu'on a pas trop le choix, ça veut dire que ces gens-là..
encore une fois entre deux maux on choisit le moindre
Bon d'abord il n'y a pas que des grosses entreprises ADP
Je prends le cas de Roland Jourdain, navigateur breton il est super engagé sur la
bio inspiration de mimétisme
il y a des gens ici en bretagne qui est le fond
mais par contre les grands groupes,  simplement c'est qu'ils ont compris que le business pour eux
il n'est pas possible avec une dégradation générale de nos environnements donc s'ils peuvent nous aider à faire un pas
je prends, après il faut être bien réfléchi sur le green washing
mais je pense que ce biomimétisme encore une fois
il faut prendre le biomimétisme dans la mesure où l'objet d'études amène à un progrès pour l'humain en général
pas uniquement pour un cahier des charges d'une seule entreprise mais c'est une question sur laquelle il faut être vigilant je suis d'accord avec vous
Par exemple Senard qui était ancien patron de Michelin a fait beaucoup pour le biomimétisme très très clairement
les groupes comme Clarins par exemple
ils ont viré toute leurs matières plastiques des crème des crèmes solaires sur une discussion un jour un coin un coin café en disant c'est
pas possible qu'on continue comme ça bon après oui il y a un argument de compétition avec une autre entreprise de produits cosmétiques
donc faut regarder mais franchement toute façon on pourra pas faire sans eux je crois
Il ne faut pas donner ça
mettre entre leurs mains puis je me suis beaucoup plus et multinationales ça c'est clair
à propos du biomimétisme on va recevoir
Agnès Guillaud et Jean Arcady Meyer qui ont sorti un livre sur le biomimétisme et c'est passionnant en même temps
Oui allez-y je vous en prie
Bonjour j'étais un peu surpris de ce que vous disiez par rapport à l'agroécologie puisqu'on voit aujourd'hui en tout cas certaines études sont sortis au niveau européen récemment
certes commandité par des mots comme avril qui sont des transnationales..
Mais qui avait l'air de dire que l'état des terres arables
en Afrique et en Inde et les besoins en terme de rattrapage nutritionnel était tel
que ce n'était pas envisageable à l'heure actuelle sans des exports de l'Europe.
Je voulais savoir quel était votre position aujourd'hui au vu des discutions que vous avez eu
Il y a un document magnifique qui a une semaine, faut vous le lisiez de commandes de France stratégie
sur l'agroécologie il y a trois tomes lisez et ils sont claires un c'est beaucoup plus rentable que le système classique pour revenir au pays qui sont
à l'extérieur bon quand je vois en Inde les niveaux de pesticide qui ont été utilisé,  l'état de dégradation des sols ça va prendre du temps
tout à fait d'accord mais il avait des solutions je prends l'herbe à éléphant en afrique
un truc qui colle les parasites vous entourer un champ avec ce machin là
pas de pesticides tout ce qui vole se colle sur le machin et ça marche donc c'est on s'est foutu d'eux alors qu'ils avaient des solutions
extraordinaires des fois de système qui permet de produire plus
puis je pense que ces gens là sont capables de produire mais j'ai vu des paysans qui font
mais toujours en polyculture tout le temps du tarot de la banane et des fleurs ça marche
je pense qu'il faut les aider à
aujourd'hui à se développer parce que c'est tellement tellement tellement tellement important le drame qui va se passer c'est dans le cadre de changements climatiques
ça va être compliqué s'il arrête de pleuvoir mais difficile
mais l'agroécologie oui on peut faire plein de choses avec ça lisez les rapports de francs stratégie !
Ils sont récupérables vraiment bien fait il montre que même en sonnant et trébuchant pour convaincre
la France quoi
bah ça rapporte plus ne serait ce que par le fait qu'on ne fait pas de pesticides et qu'on empoisonne personne
Pensez vous que les technologies basées sur les blocs chain
peuvent être un début de réponse sur le point économique, je sais pas ce que c'est..
Je connais pas assez bien le sujet des block chain
Je sais que ça existe, j'en ai entendu parler mais ne suis pas compétent pour répondre à une telle question peut être que quelqu'un pourrait m'aider là dessus
Il y à une question qui me plait beaucoup, si je la comprend bien..
Est-ce que les bactéries contenues dans le corps humain
peuvent redonner vie à une terre morte ou très pauvres en vie bactériologique ? En gros est ce que nos cadavres peuvent nourrir la terre ?
Ce qui est terrible c'est que j'ai des amis qui sont légiste, on ouvre un cercueil deux ans après le type il est intacte à l'intérieur
parce qu'ils était bourré d'antibiotiques au moment où il decède
ou bien alors les cercueils sont trop étanches, il y à pleins d'aspects là-dessus
non ce qui est clair c'est que on peut redonner de la vie à la terre ça c'est sûr avec les bactéries du sol
mais ce qui marche très bien c'est un peu dégoûtant mon truc mais ça marche sur une personne très obèse..
On lui injecte du caca de type svelte et il maigri et ça marche.
Non...
Si, ça marche !
Des fèces d'un type maigre chez un gros et il perd du poids, bien plus qu'en faisant du sport.
Donc vous voyez c'est dégoûtant mais ça marche montre
Bon on s'arrête là pour ce soir en remerciant...
On fait un peu de scato pour finir !
Merci merci beaucoup
à vous tous d'être venus nous rejoindre ce soir merci aux internautes qui ont suivi notre
conférence que vous pouvez revoir donc à partir de demain sur le site de l'espace des sciences et sur notre chaîne youtube
que vous pouvez revoir aussi sur TVR pour ce vous si vous pouvez dire aux gens qu'ils ne peuvent pas venir aux conférences
qui peuvent revoir nos conférences aussi sur TVR
le vendredi
le dimanche et le lundi
à des horaires qui sont indiqués.. Sur leur programme.
J'ai laissé un papier qui s'appelle "notre ennemi n'est pas le virus, mais nous même"
Bien sûr, sur le site de l'Espace des Sciences
Et puis merci à toute l'équipe qui a permis d'organiser cette conférence, bonsoir à tous bonne nuit à bientôt